Google Cloud NEXT '21.
Google Cloud NEXT '21
Google Cl
Google Cloud NEXT next 21
Google Cloud NEXT '21
Google Cloud NEXT ne'21
Google Cl
Google Cloud NEXT '21
Google Cloud NEXT '21.
>>JONATHAN CHAM: Hey there!
We are about six minutes from
the
kickoff of Google Cloud Next,
and I'm glad you're here.
I'm Jonathan Cham, coming to you
live from our Sunnyvale campus
with a few of my Cloud Next
colleagues.
Over the next three days, you'll
have complete access to our
keynotes, demos, Q&As and
sessions where you can engage
with our Google experts live!
And when you can't be with us in
real time, customize your
on-demand playlist to watch your
favorite content any time,
anywhere!
In the next few minutes, we're
going to share some of our
Google Cloud Partner and
Customer Award Winners, and
you'll meet a few of our
sponsors who created video
introductions just for you.
First up, check out how
Accenture combines its industry
expertise with Google Cloud's
technology to deliver
transformation.
At scale.
>>JONATHAN CHAM: It's awards
season around here, and we want
you to recognize our partners
who are on the front lines of
digital innovation and driving
exceptional results for
customers.
Today, I'm excited to share the
Google Cloud Partner Awards.
Here are our global winners in
nine industry categories.
Our reseller partner of the year
is DoiT International.
Services Partner of the Year
Deloitte.
In the Industry Solutions
Category, Capgemini.
The Breakthrough Award, TCS.
And expansion, Wix.
Our Technology Partner of the
Year, Palo Alto Networks.
Our pubPublic Sector, Deloitte.
Diversity, Equity and Inclusion
Partner of the Year is GoPomelo.
And finally, our social Social
Partner of the Year award goes
to Atos.
To see all of our winners
recognized across regions, check
out our Web site.
Congratulations to our global
winners, and a big thank you to
all of our Google Cloud partners
that are enabling and
accelerating Cloud
transformation for our customers
every day.
Next up, meet
Atos Maven Wave, a leading
Google Cloud digital
transformation partner with more
than 11 partner specializations
and four-time Google Services
Partner of the Year award
winner.
Most recently, the company was
named Global Social Impact
Partner of the Year.
Here's more.
>> In the digital first world,
innovation has no limits.
Seamless digital transformation
that modernizes business, hybrid
work environments for on-demand
collaboration, and Cloud
integration that optimizes work
flow.
The fastest, smoothest path to
digital transformation,
engineered by Google Cloud, made
easier by Maven Wave and Atos.
>>JONATHAN CHAM: And now, I'm
thrilled to announce the
Inaugural Google Cloud Customer
Awards.
These awards recognize customers
that innovate and create
industry-leading solutions and
exceptional customer experiences
with Google Cloud.
There are some truly outstanding
success stories impacting our
world in countless ways, which
is why it's my honor to present
to you our Customer Award
winners of 2021 in the following
categories:
Social impact.
Diversity, Equity & Inclusion.
Cross-industry.
We have multiple winners in this
category.
Retail.
Again, lots of winners in this
category as well.
Manufacturing.
Communications and Service
Providers.
Moving on to financial services.
Again, many winners in financial
services.
Gaming.
Healthcare and Life Sciences.
Media and Entertainment.
Government.
And our final customer award in
the category of education.
Congratulations to all our
winners!
Google Cloud is proud to be a
part of your story.
And finally, we want to thank
all our sponsors for being great
partners and continuing to
support us, including Deloitte,
our four-time Global Services
Partner of the Year winner.
Here's how Deloitte can help
with your digital transformation
journey.
[Music].
>>JONATHAN CHAM: Thanks for
watching our Cloud Next '21
pre-show.
We'd like to thank our sponsors:
Accenture, Atos Maven Wave, and
Deloitte.
Thanks to our partners and our
customers, and congratulations
to all our award winners!
We hope you enjoy these three
days of Next.
Be sure to build your custom
playlist, share it on social,
and join the conversation on
twitter and Linked in with
#GoogleCloudNext.
Now, stay right here.
The live keynote is about to
begin!
>>ALISON WAGONFELD: Hi,
everyone!
I'm Alison Wagonfeld with Google
Cloud.
Welcome to Google Cloud NEXT,
and thank you to our Google
orchestra composed of bay area
Googlers.
orchestra, composed of Bay Area
We're coming to you live from
our Google Cloud campus in
Silicon Valley, where I'm here
with Sundar Pichai and Thomas
Kurian!
We have an incredible lineup
over the next three days with
live keynotes, demos and Q&A
with our leadership, and over
140 sessions covering all our
Cloud solutions.
Our customers and partners will
share how they're using Google
Cloud and Google Workspace
technology to tackle their
greatest challenges and
opportunities.
We're humbled to support their
work and share their stories.
Thank you for being here with
us.
Now please join me in welcoming
Google and Alphabet CEO, Sundar
Pichai!
>>SUNDAR PICHAI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google Cloud Next
2021.
We're happy you're here.
Of course, I'd be happier if you
could actually be here, in
person.
Don't get me wrong, Thomas is
Great company, but he still
doesn't laugh at my container
jokes.
So while many of us are still
waiting for a return to normal,
it does feel like we're on our
way.
The question is, will we
recognize normal when we get
there?
The pandemic has sped up
digitization in all aspects of
our lives.
It's changed how we visit the
doctor, how our kids learn in
school, and how we connect with
one another.
And it's made the future of work
our present, giving us renewed
opportunity to transform our
organizations.
From our work with customers,
Thomas and I have learned there
are three things that position
us to be most helpful to
businesses: First, our Cloud
platform.
It's designed to help
enterprises transform through
digitization, built on the deep
investments we've made in
technical infrastructure over
the past 23 years.
Looking at our networking and
data center investments alone,
we have the largest network with
the lowest-latency of any Cloud
provider.
With our expansions into Warsaw,
Delhi, Melbourne and Toronto
this year, we now have 28
regions, with plans for ten
more.
And it's all connected by 19
subsea cables.
Our Grace Hopper trans-Atlantic
cable will be the first to
incorporate novel optical fiber
switching.
Second, our enterprise customers
Benefit from our consumer scale
and innovation.
We have a deep and broad
consumer ecosystem of devices
and services.
YouTube connects a global
community of viewers and
creators.
Android, Nest, Assistant, and
Maps are loved by people around
the world.
We have the unique ability to
connect consumer ecosystems with
enterprise ecosystems.
For example, the realistic
voices and language
understanding that powers Google
Assistant can improve enterprise
customer experiences and
increase satisfaction.
And the underlying visual
technology that enables Google
Lens to help people shop or
Learn about a new flower in
their garden can help
manufacturers identify defects.
Third, we offer comprehensive
security that helps
organizations, including ours,
protect what matters.
Security is foundational to
everything we do.
We have a long history of
building it into every layer of
the computing environment.
We're a pioneer of zero-trust
computing, and have deep
experience running this model at
scale.
On its own, any one of these
pillars would be helpful to
customers.
Put together, they can be
transformative, which is the
mission of Google Cloud.
We continue to drive innovation
through our products.
Over the past year, we've had
more than 1,500 product and
feature releases.
That's about four a day.
They're all designed to be
helpful, from Smart Canvas in
Google Workspace that makes
collaboration richer, to new
AI-powered industry solutions,
and Big Query Omni for data
analytics across any Cloud.
We've also made significant
partnership announcements.
For example, we teamed up with
global telecom leaders such as
Ericsson, Nokia and T-Systems to
deliver 5G edge and hosted
computing solutions.
What I'm most excited about is
how our strengths in Cloud,
Consumer and Security are
helping top enterprises
accelerate their transformation.
Ford chose Google as their
transformation partner because
of our strength in consumer and
cloud.
Together, we're innovating in
electrification, connectivity
and self-driving technologies.
Ford is harnessing Google Maps
to help drivers navigate, Google
Assistant to help drivers
concentrate, and Google Play to
keep passengers learning and
entertained.
L'Oreal partnered across Google
to build a virtual try-on
experience.
They are harnessing the best AI
models as well as YouTube to
build a community of fans, and
Google Shopping to make it easy
to discover and buy their
products.
We are humbled that so many
organizations continue to put
their trust in Google Cloud.
And we are committed to helping
you solve the biggest challenges
you face.
I'll be back a little later to
talk more about how we do that.
But first, I'll turn the stage
over to Thomas Kurian, CEO of
Google Cloud, to talk more about
our vision.
>>THOMAS KURIAN: Thank you,
Sundar!
Hello, everyone.
It is a pleasure to be here on
Google's Silicon Valley campus
today for the moment we all look
forward to all yearlong, the
opportunity to connect with you,
our customers, partners and
developers, and to share all the
amazing, exciting stuff we've
been working on.
A special thank you to all our
sponsors, especially our
Luminary Sponsors, Accenture,
Atos/Maven Wave, and Deloitte.
Let's first hear from some of
our customers about the amazing
ways in which they have
accelerated transformation with
Google Cloud.
>> The pandemic really did
accelerate the digital wave of
change by easily three to five
years.
>> We transitioned to all
virtual care.
>> We're better positioned to
accelerate.
>> Cross over to today, we have
a truly profound permanent
structural transformation.
>> Now our team with look at
hundreds of calls in minutes
instead of weeks.
>> Our business has really been
transformed with the help of
Google Cloud.
>> We have spikes in demand.
We can scale four times in less
than five minutes.
>> Transforming the way
scientists are developing drugs,
chemical spaces almost inspint.
We can do things we couldn't do
before.
>> We think we can help solve
that for the supply chain.
>> How can we help workers with
artificial intelligence?
>> Suddenly, lots of ideas
become interesting.
>> We're very excited to develop
our artificial intelligence and
machine learning.
>> Access to innovation, the
speed of innovation.
>> We're rethinking, retaining
and pioneering simplicity.
>> The partnership with Google
Cloud provides us with
technology that will drive us to
be better.
>>THOMAS KURIAN: Now, it is not
a secret that many of the
biggest and most innovative tech
companies, leaders such as
Spotify, twitter, Shopify,
Mercado Libre, ShareChat, Dapper
Labs, and so many other exciting
startups and tech leaders choose
Google Cloud to help them build,
scale and innovate.
Still, other customers are
transforming
using our purpose-built industry
solutions.
The Home Depot, for instance,
used contact center AI to reduce
customer
resolution time by 91 million
minutes.
Procter and Gamble creates
personalized omni-channel
journeys from over 275 million
consumer records.
IKEA Retail used Recommendations
AI to increase eCommerce
click-thru rates by 30 percent,
And increase order value by 2
percent.
FIH, a Foxconn company, used
Visual Inspection to identify
defects ten times more
accurately.
Mr. Cooper, a leading mortgage
services provider, used Document
AI to process mortgage documents
400 percent more efficiently.
And bank of network Mellon
liquidity solution that predicts
nearly 40 percent of securities
settlement failures with 90
percent accuracy.
We are helping MANY businesses
drive durable innovation through
long-term partnerships with
Google's Transformation Cloud.
To help them transform, we focus
on five key themes.
One, are we the best at
understanding and using data in
our industry?
Two, do we have the
Industry's leading technology
infrastructure?
Three, are we creating the best
hybrid workplace for our
passionate and talented
employees?
Four, do we know that our data,
systems and users are secure
now, and that they will be
secure in the future?
And five, are we working
together to address the most
important challenges facing our
world?
We help organizations address
these important questions.
Let's start with the first
question.
Are we the best at understanding
and using data in our industry?
We help organizations unify
their data across multiple
clouds and silos, combine
unstructured and structured
Data and making data every
employee's super power.
Using Data Analytics and AI
together, Schrodinger
accelerated clinical drug
discovery by 60 percent finding
new breakthroughs faster.
Like many states around the
United States, the Wisconsin
Department of Workforce
Development confronted a wave of
new unemployment claims.
Using Google's data cloud, they
clear over 750,000 unemployment
claims, reducing claim time from
weeks to days, and disbursing
over $2 billion in unemployment
benefits.
Wal-Mart is transforming the
experience for the approximately
220 million shoppers around the
globe who visit a Wal-Mart
store, club or eCommerce Web
site each week.
I'm honored today to welcome
Suresh Kumar, executive vice
president
President, Wal-Mart's Global
Chief Technology Officer, and
Chief Development Officer.
>> Hi, Thomas, and hello,
everyone!
I'm excited to be here today to
share about how we at Wal-Mart
are innovating on behalf of our
customers, our associates, and
the role that our partners like
you, Google, have played in our
innovation journey.
Now, I came to Wal-Mart at a
time of incredible digital
transformation, and jointly with
my team, created a robust
execution plan to accelerate the
transformation across three
areas: Building great customer
experiences, optimizing our
business, and modernizing our
platform and our infrastructure.
Each of these three priorities
are individually important, but
when you bring them together, in
the scale of a business like
Wal-Mart, it has a massive
impact.
If you move at speed, you can
completely transform global
operations and disrupt entire
industries.
Some of our most data intensive
are critical decisioning process
are getting the big credit
treatment.
Through this, not only are we
seeing significant savings like
we'll continue as we migrate
more and more data over, we are
also seeing the ability to use
the data in interesting ways,
including enabling analytics at
scale, and turning data into
actionable insights.
From a data migration to big
Query standpoint, 97 percent of
the tables used for data
warehouse have already migrated
to the cloud, and 30 percent of
with plans to almost double that
by the end of this fiscal year.
And the cherry on the top is
that BigQuery has allowed us to
integrate with pretty much any
data visualization tool and
analytics tool that's out there.
Thereby, improving our
processing time by 23 percent,
and, of course, needless to say,
a much better user experience.
Using BigQuery has had a direct
impact on our business.
And a current example is our
ability to close our financial
books in three days instead of
five days, and that's a pretty
big deal.
Leveraging our Cloud has enabled
us to unleash the potential of
AI across our entire business.
This goes from predicting demand
to managing in-stock levels to
optimizing supply chain, to
freeing up time for our
associates to serve our
customers.
As one example, express delivery
which is our two-hour delivery
service, which we launched last
year, actively uses AI behind
the scenes as the customer is
creating their order.
Mul
Multiple -- work in unison to
optimize the delivery route and
determine if the customer is
eligible for express delivery.
We are building our own AI
capabilities to power multiple
areas of our business including
classification, natural language
processing, forecasting,
regression, computer vision,
predictions, process automations
and a whole lot more.
So to wrap up, I'm really
excited about the opportunity
Wal-Mart has to drive innovation
and to further disrupt the
retail industry.
I hope you will agree that our
work together is making a huge
difference for our customers and
our associates.
Thank you for having me!
>>THOMAS KURIAN: Thank you,
Suresh.
Tens of thousands of incredible
organizations, like Wal-Mart,
choose Google's Data Cloud for
four reasons: First, Google's
Data Cloud is the most complete
and unified data and AI platform
to help you manage every stage
of the data life cycle, from
running operational transactions
to developing analytical
applications.
We help customers unify data
lakes and warehouses as data
lakehouses to reduce complexity
and to combine structured and
unstructured data.
Built-in Data Science and AI
with support for MapReduce,
Spark and Presto enable
continuous learning and
experimentation.
And, we support real-time
streaming that natively uses
open source standards like Beam
and Flink.
Google's Data Cloud is unmatched
for speed, scale, security and
reliability.
BigQuery, one of the most
successful and beloved data
warehouse solutions with its
unique serverless approach,
during a typical week helps more
than 3,000 different
organizations analyze more than
200 petabytes of data.
And thousands of customers use
Dataproc to run Spark and
Hadoop clusters easily.
Spanner, a fully managed
relational database with
unlimited scale and multi-zone
and multi-region consistency
serves more than one billion
requests per second and provides
a five 9 SLA.
Google Data Cloud's Vertex AI
offers the AI pioneered at
Google Research and DeepMind, so
that every data scientist and ML
engineers can build, deploy and
scale AI Models faster and with
80 percent less code, using AI
the same way Google does.
For instance, GE Appliances, an
appliance manufacturing leader
for more than a century, is
using Google Cloud, including AI
at the edge, to build innovative
digital products with
over-the-air updates.
And finally, Google's Data Cloud
is more open standards-based.
You can choose from Postgres, My
SQL, Redis, MongoDB, or migrate
from Oracle or SQL Server.
And we have strategic
Partners with leading
data-driven applications
.
For instance, C3 AI has made its
entire lineup of AI software
Based applications available on
Google Cloud.
Our customers can analyze,
govern and visualize data from
many databases and storage
systems on Google or other
Clouds, including all of
Google's databases, Google
Sheets, BigQuery, using LOOKER,
our premier BI and embedded
analytics solution.
You know, today, we are thrilled
and excited to announce that we
will be
integrating Tableau, a leader in
data visualization, with Looker,
Google Sheets, and BigQuery.
Tableau customers will soon be
able to use Looker's semantic
model, enabling new levels of
data governance and access to
data.
Let's take a look.
Aleks, over to you.
In this demo, we're going to
show you how you can seamlessly
use Looker and Tableau together
to answer your critical business
questions.
Let's say I work at an eCommerce
company and our Looker model
provides a consistent view
across the organization for our
most important business metrics.
Here, for example, you can see
the definition for gross margin.
Our Looker dashboard is based on
that same semantic model.
Since it provides trusted
insights at a glance, I can
immediately see that sales are
up.
However, did I miss anything?
Let's find out.
Say I'm more comfortable working
in spreadsheets.
I can now take advantage of the
new integration between Looker
and Google Sheets.
With a couple of clicks, I have
access to my governed and
trusted Looker data in Sheets,
and I can easily connect to my
data models.
To understand which factors are
impacting sales, I'll drag and
drop fields from my model into a
pivot table to break out sales
by category over time.
Since it's pulling from Looker,
I can trust that all the data
definitions are consistent.
I can use familiar Sheets
formulas and formatting to get
insights faster and understand
how specific products are
selling.
We see a notable downward trend
month over month for activewear.
I want to share these findings
with my marketing team, who's
using Tableau.
Now I can use the new Tableau
and Looker integration to
combine data from my Looker data
model with marketing data to
build a more comprehensive view
of my business.
Next, I'm going to plot sales by
category, and then add marketing
spend to the view.
Tableau makes it easy for me to
drill down on relevant data.
Now I can see that social
marketing spend was
significantly lower for
activewear, and this is why
there's a downward trend in
activewear sales.
I'm going to publish this result
on Tableau online and tag my
marketing team so they can take
action.
Leveraging integrations between
Tableau, Sheets, and Looker,
allows our teams to build
powerful visualizations using
trusted data.
We can then share these
visualizations throughout our
organization to drive informed
decisions, action, and impact.
Back over to you, Thomas.
>>THOMAS KURIAN: The second
question customers ask is, do we
have industry-leading technology
infrastructure?
We're experiencing great
momentum with our Open
Infrastructure Cloud.
Many of the most demanding and
technically advanced customers
in the world disproportionately
choose us.
Take, for example, leading media
companies and streaming
services, such as
Univision and Globo, the largest
media group in Latin America,
use our very high performance
networking, computing and
storage to broadcast media,
including live events such as
the recent Tokyo Olympics.
Leading telecommunications
companies are also choosing
Google Cloud.
Reliance Jio, the world's second
largest mobile carrier, is
automating its 5G network,
Vodafone is processing over a
billion network events each day,
AT&T is delivering new
multi-access edge computing
solutions, and Telus is
migrating critical IT and
network workloads, all to Google
Cloud.
You know, leading data
management
companies, including Databricks,
Redis, Cockroach DB, Couchbase,
Elastic, Influx Data, MariaDB,
MongoDB, Neo4J, and Singlestore
are all growing faster on Google
Cloud than on any other Cloud
And they love our storage
scaleability and advanced
infrastructure.
MongoDB, for instance, has more
net new customers via Google
Cloud Marketplace than any other
Cloud.
Leading cybersecurity companies,
such as Palo Alto Networks,
Exabeam, F5 Shape, Splunk,
Broadcom, and Forgerock are also
choosing Google Cloud for its
performance, global scale and
underlying security.
Customers are migrating and
transforming SAP and VMware
workloads to Google Cloud.
In the last year, we've added
three times the number of SAP
customers as the prior year, and
we're accelerating.
Paypal, for instance, has an
SAP/HANA scale out supporting 40
million business transactions
daily and 200 billion records
touched in 30 seconds.
Mitel, in Canada, migrated over
1,000
1,000VM wear virtual machine in
less than 90 days
to Google Cloud VMware Engine.
Nylas, an API platform company,
chose our Tau VM's with Google
Kubernetes Engine, as they saw
over 40 percent better price
performance than on a
competitor.
Customers choose our open Cloud
infrastructure for three main
reasons: First, we make your
path to migrate and modernize
using the Cloud easy with
migration tools, new serverless
and container capabilities, and
Managed services as your
developers spend more time
building experiences that your
customers love.
Second, we offer transformative
capabilities with cutting edge
performance and security.
And our network offers three
times the throughput of other
Cloud providers.
Third, we remain, and were, the
very first and only Cloud
provider with a clear,
multi-cloud strategy.
We provide you with a consistent
developer experience built on
open source to write once and
deploy anywhere.
Many customers like Plaid, a
financial services leader, use
Anthos to deploy, operate and
manage applications across
multiple clouds.
Recently, we introduced Anthos
for
virtual machines, standardizing
the way you manage applications
Across both virtual machines and
containers.
For multi-cloud data, BigQuery
Omni lets customers analyze data
across Google Cloud, AWS and
Azure.
With it, Johnson & Johnson was
able to combine data in Google
Cloud and AWS S3 with BigQuery
Omni without needing to migrate
data.
Customers also want to expand
where they use Google Cloud,
whether in their private data
Centers or out on the edge.
For instance, some workloads
cannot move to the public cloud
entirely due to the need for
large amounts of local data
Processing, extremely low
latency, or strict regulations.
To solve these challenges, we're
Announcing today, Google
distributed Cloud, a portfolio
of hardware
and software solutions that
extend our infrastructure to the
Edge and even into your own data
center.
To tell you more about it,
please welcome Ines from our
Google Cloud distriDistributed
Team.
>> Thank you, Thomas.
Google Distributed Cloud is a
set of fully managed services
running on Google managed
hardware.
Based on open API's and built on
Anthos, it gives customers
greater deployment flexibility
and ensures more consistent
operations across hybrid and
multi-cloud environments.
More than any other Cloud
provider.
There are four deployment
scenarios depending on your
specific needs.
Google's Network Edge.
This allows customers to
leverage over 140 network edge
locations around the world.
Operator Edge.
This scenario is designed to
accommodate emergency services
and applications with a
stringent latency and
reliability requirements for a
specific operator.
Customer edge, this scenario
supports customer's own edge
locations such as retail stores,
factory floors or branch
offices, which require localized
compute and processes.
And finally, customer data
centers.
This deployment option is
specific to customer-owned data
centers and co-facilities.
Google Distributed Cloud also
includes a hosted mode to run
sensitive workloads and address
data, sovereignty, security and
privacy requirements.
It does not require connectivity
to Google Cloud at any time to
manage infrastructure, services,
APIs or tooling.
You have the choice to manage it
yourself, or host through a
designated trusted partner.
Back to you, Thomas.
>>THOMAS KURIAN: Thank you,
Ines.
Partners like HPE, Dell, Cisco
and NetApp are key as we deploy
Google Distributed Cloud
globally on best-of-class
hardware.
I am pleased to announce the
expansion of our NetApp
partnership in two ways.
First, NetApp is our primary
partner supporting Google's
Distributed Cloud storage
infrastructure.
Second, for customers utilizing
Google Cloud VMware Engine, they
now have preview access for
NetApp Cloud Volumes.
We are the only hyperscaler to
provide customers with this
choice.
Deep partnerships with T-Systems
and Thales have also enabled us
to address the evolving
sovereignty requirements for
Cloud technology in Germany and
France.
The next question we hear is,
how can we provide the best
environment to help employees
create and innovate together,
especially in a hybrid
workplace?
Hybrid is redefining how we
All work, making it less about
where we work, but more about
the quality of our experience.
Studies estimate that more than
48 percent of employees will
work remotely post-COVID.
Google Workspace is the best
platform for hybrid Work with
Simple, powerful and secure
tools to help people
communicate and collaborate with
one another, no matter where
they are.
We introduced Smart Canvas to
help content creators remove
friction from work flows and
enable teams to stay connected
outside of meetings to foster
well-being and reduce video call
fatigue.
We made communication and
Collaboration completely
seamless.
For instance, users can easily
present and
collaborate in meetings, create
meeting notes from Calendar,
present in Meet directly from
Docs, Sheets or Slides, and
collaborate directly from Chat
and Spaces.
We optimize collaboration from
all mobile devices to provide
great experiences for frontline
workers, who make up 80 percent
of the global workforce.
One of America's largest
hospital systems, Common Spirit
Health, is advancing its patient
care mission during the pandemic
by making its front line doctors
and nurses productive with
Google Workspace.
Since hybrid work has removed
the notion of a physical
location for work, Google wo
Workspace created spaces, a
unified digital location for
work.
Today, more than 3 billion users
move securely and seamlessly
between Mail, Chat, Audio, Video
and now spaces.
And you, too, can choose among
the over 5,300 public apps in
our marketplace and you can also
add thousands of private apps to
enhance your work space.
Now, I want to step aside for
just a minute and tell you about
a hidden secret in our portfolio
products.
Appsheet.
Our local platform that makes it
easy for everyone, not just
professional developers, to
build amazing apps and work
flows.
For instance, property managers
at car for properties used
Appsheet to build a mobile app
to log, track and resolve
problems with headquarters.
Replacing a multi-step manual
process.
We're also partnering with
Citrix, because employees
sometimes need access to windows
and Mac OS applications and desk
tops, directly served from the
cloud.
We're expanding our partnership
with Citrix today to deliver an
integrated desk top as a service
solution, purpose built on
Google Cloud.
Customers ask us, do we know
that our data, systems and users
are secure?
And how do we keep them secure
in the future?
You know, as more digital users
access more data from more
locations, the risk of cyber
security breaches is
accelerating.
By pioneering new approaches to
security, Google keeps more
people safe online than anyone
else in the world.
Take, for instance, JetBlue.
It's keeping its systems secure,
protecting the data of all its
travellers, and modernizing its
security operations use
Chronicle to detect threats
across petabytes of security
telemetry, and eliminating data
blind spots.
Commerzbank, one of Germany's
largest banks, is using our new
Certificate Authority Service to
verify machine and workload
identity, improving security,
simplifying operations and
eliminating entire classes of
threats.
Secure-by-default drives
customers to choose Google
Cloud.
First, we have implemented zero
trust at the core of our
services and our operations,
enabling you to trust nothing.
Second, we have built
cloud-scale threat detection and
response, allowing you to detect
everything.
And third, we know it's not just
about tools.
We provide the advisor services
you need to transform security
operations.
We keep customers safe with
BeyondCorp Enterprise which
enables Zero Trust Access for
all users.
Today, we're expanding Beyond
Corp to all your applications,
modern and legacy, Web and desk
top, and even to production
environments.
We keep customers safe by
eliminating software supply
chain vulnerabilities.
Over the past two decades, we
pine neared an approach to
secure our own software supply
chain.
We are now making that
technology available through the
salsa open source framework, and
as managed services in our cloud
to help you secure your own
software supply chain.
We keep customers safe by
integrating chronicle's threat
detection capability, with our
security Command Center,
allowing you to respond faster
to potential risks.
And we keep customers safe by
bringing our security expertise
to you rs with our Google
cybersecurity Action Team, a
team of our leading security
experts who can help shape your
security transformation, from
your very first implementation,
through responding to a major
incident, and engineering new
solutions as needs change.
Finally, we continue to expand
our secure ecosystem, with
companies like Fortnet, Palo
Alto Networks, Thales, and so
many more.
Today, I would like to welcome a
new security partner,
cyberreason, with whom we are
collaborating to deliver a new
extended Detection and Response
offering that will combine
Chronicle's capability with
Cybereason's Mal/Ops engine for
faster, easier threat detection
and response.
Our products, our new
Cybersecurity Action Team and
our partnerships all make the
world safer from cyberthreats.
To talk more about how we help
keep each and every one of you
secure, and how we're addressing
some of the most important
challenges facing our world, I'd
like to invite Sundar back.
Thank you.
>>SUNDAR PICHAI: Thank you,
Thomas.
Security is top of mind for
businesses of all sizes, as well
as the public sector.
And despite the progress that
has been made in cybersecurity,
large scale breaches continue to
make headlines.
That's why, in August, Google
announced we will invest $10
billion over the next five years
to strengthen cybersecurity.
That investment includes
expanding zero-trust programs,
helping secure the software
supply chain, and enhancing
open-source security.
A new challenge is keeping
collaboration secure and
private, as we move to hybrid
work environments.
To help, we're introducing a new
work Safer Program.
It provides the highest level of
security for your E-mail,
meetings, messaging and more,
and brings together Google
Workspace with Titan Security
Keys, BeyondCorp, and other
secure technologies, products
and partners.
Now every kind of organization
and business can access the same
security protections that make
work safer at Google.
Security is an issue that
affects us all.
And this brings us to the last
question Thomas posed.
Are we addressing the most
important challenges facing our
world?
Climate change is one of the
most profound challenges we
face, and it will take all of us
working together to solve it.
Sustainability has been a core
value for us for more than two
decades.
Google has been carbon neutral
since 2007, and we've matched
our operations with 100 percent
renewable energy over four
consecutive years.
Last year, we set out to make
our third decade of climate
action our biggest yet.
That included a bold commitment
to operate on 24/7 carbon-free
energy across our offices and
data centers by 2030.
And last week, we announced new
ways we're helping one billion
people make more sustainable
choices.
When it comes to enterprises,
one of the most important
sustainability choices is where
to run your technology.
IDC predicts Cloud migrations,
over the next four years, could
reduce carbon emissions by over
1 billion metric tons, or the
equivalent of removing 200
million cars off the road for a
year.
We are proud that Google Cloud
is the cleanest cloud in the
industry.
Earlier this year, we introduced
a way for customers to choose
the cleanest regions to run
their workloads.
Today, we are expanding our
portfolio of solutions and
partnerships to help reduce your
carbon footprint.
First, we are focused on giving
you
you greater transparency around
carbon emissions data.
We're announcing carbon
footprint, a new service to
measure, track and report the
gross carbon emissions
associated with your Google
Cloud usage.
Having this data at your
fingertips is really important.
And we know that many customers
track sustainability data in
other places.
That's why I'm happy to announce
that Google Cloud's emission
data will integrate directly
into Salesforce's Sustainability
Cloud.
We also want to give you the
tools to act on that data.
So today, we're introducing a
new tool that will alert you
when you have idle workloads and
make recommendations to reduce
carbon emissions.
It's all part of our goal to
help make your Cloud
transformation secure and
sustainable, and solve for
what's next.
So on behalf of Thomas and
myself, let me thank you once
again for trusting us to be a
partner with you on this
journey.
And we hope you enjoy the next
three days.
Thank you.
>> Hello, and welcome to our
very first spotlight.
I hope you enjoyed the opening
keynote.
For the next hour, we will be
diving in to all things data.
I'm Stephanie Wong, a developer
advocate, and I'm here with
Gerrit Kazmaier, who leads
database, analytics and BI
solutions at Google Cloud.
>> Thanks, Stephanie.
I am very excited to be here,
and to share with everyone what
we have been working on.
The team thought we start on the
light side of things here, and
start with a joke.
One of my favorite jokes,
actually.
So here it goes.
A SQL Query walks into a bar and
approaches two tables and asks,
can I join you?
[Drum beat].
>> Okay.
I guess we roll the video
instead.
>> Innovation is a huge
challenge in baseball.
The current MLB fan expects us
to be relevant.
>> Customers call us.
Patients call us.
Members call us.
And you can imagine a team
that's just buried under the
weight of thousands of call
recordings.
>> We look at so much data.
Everything you can imagine, we
analyze.
>> Frankly, we spend 70 percent
of our time just trying to
capture it, and trying to sift
through it.
>> We're expecting to transfer
or run 300 to 400 petabytes to
the cloud.
It's hard to even describe how
big that is.
>> Google Cloud was very
impressive to us.
It allowed us flexibility in
storage and compute scaling.
>> Google Cloud provides us with
technology that will drive us to
be better.
>> Now our team can look at
hundreds of calls a day, in
minutes instead of weeks.
>> With Google Cloud, we're
going to be able to spend our
time analyzing real-time and
using the data that we've been
collecting.
>> We thought Google Cloud was
the best partner for us.
>> I think this is very much
going to be an open and
evolving, long-term relationship
between Google and twitter.
>> It's a perfect fit with
Google Cloud as we go forward.
>> Google's made it possible for
us to reach exceptional customer
experience in a way that hasn't
been done before.
>> And welcome back.
So what are we solving for
today?
This spotlight session is about
how to leverage data as your
most strategic business asset,
especially as you adapt to and
anticipate change.
Data has the power to transform
stagnant businesses into
profitable ones, streamline
operations to improve people's
lives, and identify areas of
waste to radically reduce
unnecessary spending.
It can be used to solve
businesses and world problems,
both the simple ones and the
ones that keep people up at
night.
It has the potential to
accelerate progress faster than
a think tank or world summit.
And it's largely untapped.
As you learn more about Google
Cloud capabilities and make
progress on your data Cloud
journey, you can unlock your own
10X mindset as external factors
accelerate the pace of change.
Never before have we faced this
much uncertainty, and now is the
time when every company can turn
data into an ability.
The reality today is that too
many companies struggle to
remove the barriers to turn data
into intelligence.
>> This is exactly what we are
seeing with our customers,
turning data into intelligence
and delivering value is no
longer a nice to have.
It is essential.
A recent study shows that only
32 percent of the companies
surveyed gain value from their
data investments, and this is
the result of
difficult-to-access, slow,
unreliable, complex and
fragmented systems.
Many companies just feel
overwhelmed with the demand for
the various types of working
with data, and of doing it at
scale.
They feel walled in with a lack
of integration, a lack of
openness, a lack of portability,
and very poor APIs.
It is time to re-imagine our
data cloud strategy that is
unlocking your data advantage.
Build great applications that
understand and interact with
your customer, and operational
databases that scale to billions
of queries per second, react on
any event in real times and
process millions of data
streams, analyze petabytes of
data without sizing or tuning
your data warehouse anymore, and
ultimately, optimize your
processes with hundreds of
machine learning models in
production.
This is how you unlock your data
cloud and unlock your data
advantage.
To build your data cloud, you
need your systems to be simple.
And this requires a partner that
meets you where you are today,
and helps you to mature where
you want to be, but at your own
pace.
Making the complex simple is our
business.
It has been for decades,
building systems that mask the
complexity of the entire
internet behind a simple, single
interface, and building
applications with billions of
users.
It all runs on data and
analytics.
So you can say that data is our
DNA, and we can't predict the
future, but we can plan for it.
And we are deeply grateful to
work with tens of thousands of
organizations who built their
data clouds on Google Cloud and
unlocked ultimately their data
advantage from databases to
analytics to streams to lakes to
AI, and built a unified data
cloud together with us.
>> It's leaders like you who are
accelerating their use of data
to transform complexity into
simplicity.
This week at Next, you'll hear
from leading organizations that
have chosen Google Cloud for
their data Cloud strategy over
market alternatives.
Verizon Media is one of these
customers.
Verizon uses BigQuery and Lookie
to scale their massive
enterprise media warehouse,
supporting monthly scans with
more than one exabyte of data.
The performance improvements
include 90 percent plus
productivity improvements across
the board, and lower overall TCO
compared to other Cloud
providers.
Almost overnight, traffic to
Chess.com tripled.
The pandemic and successful
series, "The Queen's Gambit"
created a perfect storm.
Ten years worth of growth
occurred in just six months, and
daily active users rose from
280,000 to more than one
million.
There's no way to handle that
surge without the move to Google
Cloud.
Using BigQuery's near infinite
ability to scale in response to
demand, this meant that
Chess.com didn't have to
forecast site traffic and worry
about unexpected surges or waste
money by over-provisioning
servers that go unused.
>> Take Auto Trader.
It's U.K.'s largest online
automotive marketplace and they
were able to migrate more than
60 percent of their current
Oracle footprint to Cloud SQL.
Auto trader builds their data
cloud by leveraging Cloud SQL,
BigQuery and Looker to deliver
access to their data to all of
their users, and with Cloud SQL
as a fully managed service, Auto
Trader release cadence has
improved by over 140 percent
year over year, enabling an
impressive peak of more than 450
releases to production on a
single day.
And this is how you build your
data advantage.
>> When Cardinal Health migrated
to Google Cloud, they enabled
disaster recovery, increased
their ability to respond to
business challenges, and
leveraged machine learning to
drive business efficiencies, all
while reducing their cost by 25
percent.
We would like to welcome Ray
Bajaj CTO of Cardinal Health to
share their data transformation
story.
Ray, thank you so much for
joining us here today.
>> Thanks, Stephanie.
And I'm really happy to be here
today.
Cardinal Health is a pioneer in
healthcare industry for
leveraging the Cloud as our
primary source of
infrastructure, achieving our
Cloud transformation journey
with more than 80 percent of our
workload fully migrated on to
the Cloud.
Our journey to Google Cloud
started in 2018, leveraging the
security and flexibility of
Google Cloud allows us to scale
and innovate at lower cost,
which empowers the organization
to focus on building the future
of healthcare and driving better
outcomes across the healthcare
ecosystem.
>> So why Google Cloud?
>> With Google, we can deliver
modern data insights
Capabilities to our engineering
teams so that they can transform
our
whole business, while also
improving the customer
experience, helping the
organization evolve in adjacent
areas of healthcare.
We also selected Google Cloud
because of its ability to
partner with SAP and run massive
ERP workloads reliably.
>> Now, what outcomes have you
been able to realize as a result
of this?
>> We leverage Google's Looker
and BigQuery to develop episode
analytics, a data-driven,
predicted cost-tracking tool
that enables community and
quality practices to accurately
measure the cost of care and
provides clearer insights in to
value-based performance.
>> Well, ray, Cardinal is
clearly at the forefront of
these shifts, and we can't wait
to see what's in store for you.
So thank you so much for being
here with us today.
>> Thank you.
>> Organizations like Cardinal
Health are solving complex
challenges with Google Cloud.
But what is holding others back
from using data to accelerate
innovation?
Companies are looking for
solutions that can simplify
their data landscape to move
from a state where every
scenario requires a new tool to
an agile platform that combines
data analytics, databases, data
engineering and science,
security and governance into a
single platform.
To move from data at rest to a
platform where data is
accessible in real-time.
>> Our vision is to provide a
platform that allows data to
unfold its full potential.
Ultimately, enabling us to reach
new horizons ranging from newly
built digital experiences,
products and business models to
advanced machine learning and
AI, to ultimately empowering
humans to reason beyond their
own biological capacity.
And we have built the industry's
most simple, intelligent and
best integrated cloud data
platform that enables businesses
to fuel their own digital
transformation.
And this is how you unlock your
data advantage, to seize new
opportunities, improve
operational efficiencies and
deliver new use experiences that
delight customers, partners and
your employees.
Thanks to you, our customers and
partners, Google's data platform
is one of the fastest growing
clouds fueled by the demand for
products like BigQuery.
And here comes the most exciting
part.
Today, we are excited to
announce a number of new product
innovations.
And the first announcement goes
out to all of the data engineers
in the world who are using Spark
on Google Cloud.
Open standards are at the heart
of our Data Cloud strategy, and
at Google, we follow an open
approach that enables
flexibility and choice.
And today, I'm excited to
announce Project Big Spark.
It is the world's first
autoscaling serverless Spark
service in existence.
And regardless of whether you
are a BigQuery user, a data user
or a cloud AI user, we have
created an integrated ecosystem
around spark that the factor
standard for data engineering
workloads.
We want to make it easy for you
to onboard on our platform of
Spark and never limit your
ambition with data science and
data engineering.
>> Our long history in the open
source community has shown us
that betting on the community
first is always the right
strategy to give our customers
portability and optionality.
We're excited to make Spark a
first-class citizen on our
platform, and to automate the
productionalization of our data
engineering and data science
workloads.
>> The next announcement goes to
all of the data scientists.
As enterprises consolidate their
data platforms, the distinction
between advanced analytics and
data science and machine
learning is really diminishing.
Today, more than ever, data
scientists are looking for
unified interface to be able to
seamlessly connect their entire
data estate, and also run all
explorations with SQL, Spark and
auto machine learning libraries.
With Vertex AI, we have
simplified the experience for
data scientists with 80 percent
less code required to train a
model compared to any other
platform.
As a product of Google's Vertex
AI's credit sheet, I am happy to
announce the preview of AI
Notebook for Vertex AI, that
offers a fully managed, scalable
and enterprise-grade IDE
combined with easily enforceable
policies and user management.
>> These AI Notebook innovations
are great examples of Google
bringing together the power of
data and AI.
Google truly aims to fast-track
innovation by eliminating the
need for data scientists to
shift context between aspects
like data analytics, data
science and machine learning.
>> That is right on.
And here is an exciting
announcement to all of the
developers.
We are adding a Postgres
interface for Spanner, which
continues our commitment to
openness and reinforces our
efforts to democratize the
access to Spanner.
With this new Postgres
interface, enterprises can take
advantage of Spanner's unmatched
global scale, five 9's of
availability, and strong
consistency, using skills and
tools from the popular Postgres
ecosystem, and starting today,
you can create a Spanner
database that uses Postgres SQL
dialect and connect with its
open wire protocol.
This interface supports
Spanner's rich feature set,
using the most popular Postgres
data types and SQL features, and
thus, democratizing access to
Spanner for millions of
developers out there.
Our commitment to the ecosystem
has been longstanding, with
ongoing support for Cloud SQL,
for my SQL, Postgres, and SQL
Server, so you can lift and
shift your databases.
Our mission with Cloud SQL is
compatibility, and we were the
first cloud provider to support
Postgres 13.
>> These announcements are so
exciting, because Postgres has
emerged as a popular choice for
operational databases.
Postgres is known and loved for
its stability and feature set
and has built an active and
growing ecosystem of developers
and tools.
Our investments in Postgres are
a step in the right direction to
continue meeting developers
where they are, with the tools
they love.
>> We are excited to announce
new ways to help organizations
going beyond traditional
business intelligence to
analyze, access and act on data.
Looker continues to integrate
with the other offerings in our
portfolio, as well as continues
to innovate with our core
product.
And to address the needs, we are
continuing to simplify the
experience across BigQuery,
Looker and Data Studio, together
with Connected Sheets.
Today, we are announcing new
enhancements which bring the
reality of augmented analytics
to more people with Looker
solution for Contact Center AI
to help businesses leverage AI
and converse naturally with
customers and deliver
outstanding experiences.
We are also announcing a new
Looker block for healthcare NLP
AI, which creates a user
interface to advance AI and
natural language functionality,
and this helps healthcare
providers to gain deeper
understandings of their patient
data.
>> Part of the secret sauce lies
in Looker's in database
architecture and semantic layer
which makes it possible for
business users to trust data, no
matter how they experience it,
via a dashboard, E-mail or text
alert, or even a custom
application.
We are excited for these recent
innovations, but we couldn't do
this alone.
Together with our community of
customers, partners and
developers, we are delivering
innovation across a variety of
use cases.
We are able to create new
solutions and accelerate your
journey to transform data in to
value.
>> Next, I want to announce an
important partnership with
Informatica.
We have partnered with
Informatica to help hundreds of
customers succeed with their
journey to the cloud.
Together, we are helping
customers move mission critical
workloads to the cloud and
integrate with Google Cloud
technologies, such as BigQuery.
Today, we are excited to
announce that we are deepening
our partnership with Informatica
even more.
First, for existing Informatica
power center customers, we are
so pleased to announce our
migration factory, which will
help to accelerate migration of
data-driven workloads to Google
Cloud with Informatica Cloud.
Second, we are pleased to
announce our new services or
Google Cloud's Marketplace,
which will include Informatica's
integration and enterprise data
catalog offerings.
And we are continuing to invest
in key product integrations with
databricks.
Our engineering and product
teams continue to work together
to deliver the joint road map,
and we have multiple customers
using our latest enterprise
security and performance
enhancements of databricks on
GKE.
In Q4, we will also deliver
databricks SQL, databricks
photon on Google Cloud, as well
as we are launching new data
center regions together in EMEA
and APEC.
Our AI teams are engaged to
allow customers to experiment
and develop models on databricks
and Vertex AI together and
deploy models at scale in to
production with Vertex ML Ops
suite.
>> So much goodness.
Okay.
Before we get into the live
demo, I recommend tuning in to
more sessions to hear from all
our customers this week.
Join the chief data officer
panel discussion, and listen to
our product strategy sessions
for database, data analytics, BI
and AI.
>> We can't wait to hear from
you.
Connect with you.
Join us in our community and
share your expertise and ask
your questions.
But most importantly, start to
build your data cloud and unlock
your data advantage.
Okay.
Time now to get hands-on and
check out our products in real
action.
Join us for live demo and
interact with our experts and
one another, and then stick
around for the live Q&A
following the demo.
I'll see you there.
>> Hi, everybody.
I'm Leah.
>> And I'm Nikita.
>> And welcome to the Data Cloud
live demo.
If you're just joining us from
this morning's keynote and
spotlight, you heard from the
latest innovations we launched.
Earth Engine, Spark on Google
Cloud, Postgres secret interface
for spanner, and workbench all
to help organizations -- and
simplify them.
Bringing together data on a
massive scale to explore a
real-world scenario for climate
and supply chain analytics.
>> In order to do this, we're
going to need the whole data
team.
Say hi, everybody.
>> Hello.
I'm Brad.
>> Hi.
I'm Derrick.
>> Now, a quick reminder.
This demo is truly live and you
can engage with us directly.
So ask questions, say hi in the
chat window, and hit those
emojis.
>> I think I see some coming in
now.
I see lots of hearts and fire.
A lot of people saying hello in
the chat.
Thanks, everyone, for joining us
today.
So if you can't see this or the
chat, just go back to the Next
Event Web site and click on the
blue join the iJoin the Interac
Experience button.
>> Okay.
You're actually joining us for
our weekly stand-up at symbol
super store, a fictional
U.S.-based grocery chain focused
on sourcing from local
producers.
Like many different industries,
we need to bring together
disparate data sources to build
resilience, specifically for us,
drought in the western U.S. has
impacted our producers, and our
supply chain has been disrupted
with decreased shipments week
over week.
>> We need to better understand
how to manage inventory, and to
prevent stock-outs, and ensure
we can scale in both how we
analyze information and how we
run our transactions.
>> All right, team.
So to address this supply and
scale changes that Nikita just
mentioned, we have four
different workloads.
First, I'm going to evaluate the
best climate information to
identify at-risk producers.
Then, Brad will mature our data
pipelines to transform that
data.
Ne, Derrick will dig in to
scaling our transaction
processing.
And finally, Nikita will show
how we're gaining new insights
by evolving our data science
capabilities.
>> Let's get into it and let's
keep hearing from all of you out
there, our data pros.
Leah, you're up first.
>> Great!
Thanks, Nakita.
So in order to gain insight into
our supply chain, first I need
to evaluate the risks.
So I'm focusing on figuring out
how drought impacts the very
source of our grocery products.
And to do this, I turn to
Google's platform for earth
science data and analytics,
Earth Engine, which has a huge
catalog of satellite images for
things like climate, weather,
crop lands and much more.
There's currently over, like, 50
petabytes of data in the
catalog.
Plus, more and more images are
added each day.
So let me just go ahead and
bring up this cool little
application that I built using
the Earth Engine Code Editor.
So I can walk you through the
three data sets we'll be using
today.
First is going to be crop data
from the USDA NASS Program,
which I can grab right from the
public data catalog by
searching.
This data set is going to
contain one image of the U.S.
going back all the way to 1997.
And each ten-meter pixel in this
image has actually been assigned
a crop type.
Let me just close -- the second
data set contains the outline of
agricultural fields.
And we're going to use earth
engine to assign each one of
these fields the crop type that
is most prevalent among the
sales that cover it.
So in this view that I'm showing
right here, the pink fields are
alfalfa, and the dark green
fields almonds.
>> Leah, these fields are super
helpful, but can we export this
data for analysis in other
environments?
>> Yep.
I'm actually going to push this
in to cloud storage and BigQuery
in just a second, but first I
want to add in some additional
signals on drought.
So the third data set that I'm
using is a collection of both
short and long-term kraut
drought indicators, meaning that
we can see what drought looks
like for each field.
Now, using data sets like these
does require some deep subject
matter expertise.
So special thanks to our
real-world partners at Climate
Engine who build solutions on
top of earEarth Engine's API,
helping organizations ground
their analytics projects with
scientifically accepted
methodologies.
Okay.
So you just saw how we used
geospatial data, and I want to
know how you use it in your
analysis.
So go ahead and answer that poll
so we can see.
All right, everyone.
So with these layers in place,
we can start exploring drought
risk.
Let me just go ahead and zoom to
this field.
And here, I'm going to show an
almond orchard northeast of
Modesto, California.
And overlooking that is the
long-term drought indicator.
So this orange tint that you're
seeing means that this field has
experienced pretty high levels
of drought over the last five
years.
Now, if I go ahead and just zoom
out a bit, we can actually see
that the entire central valley
in California is pretty drought
stressed.
So my last step was to calculate
drought risk for each of the
fields I showed before.
And this will tell us which
farms and produce types are
potentially at risk for not
meeting customer demand, which
is just one consideration to
inform symbols resilient
strategy.
Better yet, we can incorporate
the geography data with other
spatial stuff like store and
customer locations that are
already inside of BigQuery.
And anyone who knows me knows
that I love BigQuery.
If you agree, let me see in the
emojis.
All right.
So the code editor has been
great for interacting with Earth
Engine, but making these
calculations at scale requires a
different approach.
So I went ahead and created
earth engine tasks for batch
processing to run these
calculations over all the data
in five-day increments for this
ten years.
I also set up a cloud function
to run every five days going
forward so that we'll always
have fresh data.
Now, just as a quick recap, we
jumped into earth engine to
evaluate earth science data that
indicates climate risk for our
farm fields.
Now we'll have fresh drought
data available in Cloud storage.
So just think of the power of
integrating huge amounts of
specialized data, giving us a
complete picture of supply risk
for our business.
Oh, and I think I can see the
poll results coming in now.
It looks like lots of people are
using geospatial data for all
different kinds of things, and
if your answer wasn't in the
poll, just go ahead and let us
know in the chat.
So next up, Brad will transform
and push this data into BigQuery
so geospatial analysis with our
existing data.
So Brad, over to you.
>> Okay.
That was pretty cool, Leah.
Thanks.
All right.
So to gain more insight in to
how drought is impacting
production, my main focus has
been building out the data
transformation pipeline to push
farm field drought indicators
from cloud storage into
BigQuery.
Speaking of batch processing, as
you know, to assist with
inventory management, price
optimization and product
assortment, we use product to --
we use Google Cloud data as our
long-running clusters.
For you data pros out there, we
would love to know how you're
using Spark today so let us know
while I go ahead and pull up the
cloud Console.
So here is a data cles sisclust
we currently use.
This code is typical boiler
plate code for basic data
transformations.
In this case, we are processing
the earth engine files from
cloud storage, performing type
checking and mapping to ensure
proper ingestion in to BigQuery
using the Spark Bill Clinton
query c
BigQuery connector.
>> So this is pretty cool, but I
think having a batch work flow
that's scheduled on a
continuously running cluster
seems like it can be wasteful.
So is there any way we can make
this more efficient?
>> That's a fair point, Leah.
There is still some overhead in
management here, and for
hardened batch cases like this,
it would be preferred to have
these jobs run on their own
discrete resources.
Good news, with the new
serverless option, we can submit
a price job without submitting
any infrastructure.
These automatic capabilities,ic
spend more Dev time writing code
and less time on writing
infrastructure.
>> All right, Brad.
First off, I'm pretty sure that
you just set me up for that, and
secondly, you definitely made up
that word, auto-magic.
>> Yeah, can I get some emoji
love for that?
Anyway, I'll now go ahead and
export this notebook to a Python
file, nuings N using NNB conver.
Okay.
And next, let's go and use the
cloud SDK.
We can use the data Proc API and
call batches to submit a
serverless job.
So I'm showing you here a price
park job, but I can also submit
jobs in scholar or SQL.
With auto provision and auto
scale, no infrastructure
configuration is needed.
This helps -- powerful
distributed data processing
model.
With these capabilities, there's
no need to manually create into
clusters.
So once I've submitted the
So clearly it's been a busy week
for me, using Spark serverless
to create pipelines to push
drought data in to BigQuery, but
the efficiency equivalents we'll
gain by not needing to manage
cluster overhead will be worth
it.
Now, you can let me know in the
chat if you're as excited as I
am.
>> Okay.
Let's see how everyone's using
Spark today.
Looks like notebooks are pretty
popular.
Oh, and automation through air
flow.
That's cool, too.
Okay.
Great.
Thanks so much, Brad.
So now that we have greater
insight in to supply risks, we
need to scale our transaction
systems to handle more orders
and allow us to understand the
potential business impact of
these climate risks.
Hope
Hopefully while lowering costs.
So this brings me to Derrick,
our DBA.
Derrick, you've been focusing on
this effort, so can you let us
know where you're at today?
>> Yeah.
Absolutely, Leah.
We have a new grocery chain that
has struggled to maintain their
on prem databases as they've
grown.
There's an opportunity to solve
their underlying scaling
problems with cloud spanner.
I spent the last few weeks
evaluating spanner's ability to
scale and the ease of
maintenance while keeping strong
consistency for this point of
sale workload.
I migrated some of the chains to
spanner already.
Using granular instant sizing, I
only provisioned a portion of a
spanner node to handle the
required load.
As we move the remainder of
stores, we can easily scale up
without down time or app
changes.
>> Quick question, Derrick.
We've been really focused on
reducing the cost and complexity
of building scalable
applications, so I'm wondering
how does adding spanner impact
that effort?
>> Yeah, that's a great
question.
One way we've been doing this
inometer environments is to
standardize on postgres, a
well-established open database
that our development and ops
teams are already familiar with.
I tried to get the team to add
an elephant emoji so you all
could show some love for
Postgres, but anyway.
Spanner just announced a
Postgres interface.
This gives us the benefits of
spanner without having to
complete retrain our application
teams.
Having -- this data will help us
maintain velocity for new
features, even as our database
needs evolve.
Here.
Let me show you.
So I've connected in to our
spanner, using the SQL command
line tool.
From here, I can explore the
schema, just like I would any
other database, any other
Postgres database.
You can see that both the
Postgres data type and the
spanner data type is available
to the information schema.
So this will make it familiar to
anyone who already knows
Postgres.
>> Awesome.
Thanks, Derrick.
This is really great.
>> Absolutely.
And I highlighted how spanner
allows us to get started small
and scale as needed using
granular instant sizing, and how
the new Postgres will interface
reduces friction for our teams
already familiar with Postgres.
You can use existing data, and
I'll keep onboarding more
stores.
Nakita, I believe you need this
data for some of the BigQuery
analysis you were working on.
You've been busy figuring out
how to evolve our ability to
make sense of all this data.
Can you show us how that works?
>> Yes.
Absolutely.
I was hoping that you'd ask.
So to ensure that we're managing
stock to meet customer demand,
my focus this week was on
evolving our data science for
exploratory analysis.
I combined the transactional
data that Derrick's been working
on with the jot data that Leah
and Brad pushed in to BigQuery.
This way, we can gain insight in
to which products are most at
risk of not meeting customer
demand.
So my first step was to
integrate all of our
transactional data within
BigQuery, primarily using
Federation with Cloud SQL and
Spanner.
This provided a unified
environment for aggregation and
analysis, where we can join
transactions back to producer
details and the associated
drought risk scores.
Now, as you all know, we
recently migrated tTo Workbench
which has really, really helped
with our basic compute and
resource management.
>> Quick question, Nakita.
Is Vertex AI workbench --
>> That is an excellent
question, Derrick.
Vertex AI workbench contains
recently updated managed
notebooks to bring forth more
integrated data capabilities
into our data science
environments.
So we can ingest and analyze
data and deploy and manage ML
models all from one spot.
Now, let me show you a little
bit about what this -- after I
provisiond the new managed
notebook, my first task was to
analyze the demand on the
high-volume excuse, and with
that I used the BigQuery
connected to view the sales
data.
With Vertex AI workbench, I can
inspect BigQuery metadata,
preview tables, and automate
entirely from my notebook
environment.
Okay.
It's my turn on the emojis.
I want to see the fire emoji for
people who are as excited as I
am about being able to access
BigQuery from the notebook
interface.
I'm not the only one.
>> Hey, Nakita, hold on.
Sorry to interrupt your emoji
fest, but I see you're working
out of the lakes project but are
able to pin other projects that
you have access to, like the ops
project.
Is that new?
>> Yes.
That's correct, Brad.
Vertex AI workbench also enables
me to interact with all services
via my own identity.
It also provides code to help
build out queries and project
results.
So here, we can see -- oh, looks
like I just need to refresh.
Sorry about this.
Just going to refresh my Jupiter
lab instance here.
I guess I had it open for too
long.
>> And I guess while Nakita is
doing that, like who uses
Jupiter now?
Let's see the fire emojis
lighting up.
I personally use it a lot in my
day-to-day.
>> All right.
Thank you.
So perfect.
You can see a simple view of all
transactions by the day of week.
And Vertex workbench also allows
me to launch different kernels
entirely in the same instance.
So Brad, I think you were
working out of a notebook
earlier, is that correct?
>> Yeah.
So the data -- the back end as a
part of spark on Google Cloud.
We can access all supported
kernels on the cluster,
including High Spark.
>> Well, from my analysis, I
just needed a python kernel.
So let me show you what's going
on in this notebook and what
I've been up to this week.
You can see I did a deep dive
into the data.
I've created a heat of purchase
accounts across various
departments -- the short-term
drought index across various
crop types, like corn, dry
beans, pears and rice.
My last task, and the most
important task, was to map skews
to suppliers and calculate a
risk score based on the
aggregate field data.
So to do this I started with our
mapping table, which you can see
a sample of right here.
This helped me to determine -- I
calculated a weighted risk score
that takes into account each
product's demand and the
associated farms' overall
drought risk and you can see
each of these measurements in
this data frame right here.
Ultimately, this goal will help
us to prioritize managing items
where we're most at risk of not
meeting customer demand.
So as a quick summary, I use --
to connect -- and create a
weighted risk score for each one
of our products, combining both
climate and demand data.
Leah, I went ahead and put all
of this back in to BigQuery just
to keep it centralized.
>> Awesome.
Thanks so much, Nakita.
That risk score is going to be
huge in helping our team
understand supply risk.
So to make sure the team has a
trusted view of all this
information, I started
incorporating everything into a
worker dashboard.
Now, with Looker, we define our
metrics like average risk, using
work ML looker's data model, and
Looker uses this to compile SQL
queries and send them back.
So that our users can explore
the results of these efforts.
So let me show you this
dashboard that I've been working
on.
And first off, you can see this
custom map layer that I use to
visualize drought risk across
farm regions in the west, and
we're able to take -- geospatial
functions and drill from this
aggregate view all the way to
producer or even grocery prepped
level.
Let me show you.
So I'll drill to fields ID and
then I can jump right in to look
e
er's explore.
Maybe I want to specifically
look at products that are at
risk in this region where we're
quickly expanding.
Making all this data accessible
to the broader team is really
important, so can we make sure
that the team is aware of this
so that they know how to hold
off on coupons or advertisements
for these products?
>> Yeah.
Actually, we can set up a
schedule from Looker so that the
regional marketing teams are
always notified if new products
seem to go at risk.
So putting this all together, we
used Earth Engine to process new
earth science data signals.
We used -- to efficiently
transform geospatial data and
push drought indicators in to
BigQuery, Spanner to scale our
transaction systems, enduring we
have the infrastructure to
handle future growth, and Vertex
AI Workbench plus Looker backed
by the power of BigQuery to
evolve our data science
capabilities, and serve
important trends back to key
decision makers.
Across these services, anyone is
able to explore and take action
on insights that combine climate
data and transactions.
Now, we can understand where
products may go out of stock due
to increasing drought
conditions, and identify areas
to build resilience against
changes in our climate.
So with this geospatial
information, we're given a whole
new set of data so that we can
not only be considerate of our
customers, but also find ways to
be more considerate of our
planet.
And with that, it looks like
we're right about at time.
So thank you so much for joining
us today, as we've shown how
Google Cloud can offer a world
class experience for creating a
scalable, unifightified
platform.
And a special thanks to my
colleagues, Nakita, Derrick, for
introducing us to Spanner and
it's Postgres interoperability
and Brad, for walking us through
Spark on Google Cloud.
>> And thank you, Leah, for
showing us Looker and Earth
Engine.
Last, but certainly not least,
thank you all out there so much
for your engagement.
We love those emojis and seeing
all of your comments in the
chat.
So stay tuned for our live Q&A,
which is going to cover
everything from our spotlight
through this demo.
>> Thank you!
Bye!
>> Thanks, everyone!
>> Thanks, bye!
>> Thanks, data cloud team.
What a cool demo!
I'm Dane Hanson.
Welcome, everyone.
I'm the director of product
marketing for data cloud.
Joining me today is Garrett.
>> Hey, Dane.
I'm Garrett.
I'm the vice president of data
analytics, data basis and
Looker, and I do look forward to
everyone's questions.
>> I do, too.
A reminder that this Q&A is
live.
You can engage with us directly.
So ask your questions, say hi in
the chat, hit those emojis, and
if you can't, just go --
experience button.
>> So let us jump right in.
But before we do, I do like to
see what you like most today, so
we have quite an exciting set of
announcement, and is it for you,
let's go bigger query, Postgres
for all, or is it show me the
earth engine.
>> So while we wait for those
results, tell ple, what are you
most excited about?
>> Two things, openness and
simplicity.
All of our announcements were
made to make data more
accessible, more simple to use,
from Postgres for Spanner, from
cross cloud analytics from Omni,
everything is in the spirit of
making data simple to work with
and creating an open ecosystem
around GCP for working with
data.
>> That's right.
And being open and simple is
really what it's all about, and
it's what we saw from the demo
as well.
Just a reminder that our friends
from the live demo are sticking
around to help answer the
questions.
So you might see their faces
throughout the show.
It looks like we've got some of
the poll results.
It's all about BigQuery.
Look at those hearts come in.
So this is really good.
>> Bigger query.
>> All right.
So let's get into our first
question.
It's from Tianna.
She asks about the availability
of earth engine.
We saw the great demo earlier
from the team.
How can folks get their hands on
this?
How can they access it and
another follow-up question which
is how does it work with
BigQuery GIS.
>> Awesome.
Hey, Tianna, awesome question.
So first of all, Google Earth
Engine is now in preview, which
means that you can go to
Google.com/earth engine preview
and register, and we will be
reaching out to you to set you
up with an account.
the second key piece of what we
have seen earlier is that in
earth engine, you have a data
lake of satellite imagery, and
you get a means to do geospatial
analysis on imagery data, and
the results can be brought into
BigQuery to match them up with
all of the data you have
residing there, or using
BigQuery, for instance, as we
have seen.
so all in all, awesome package,
a lot of data and data
integration right back in to
BigQuery.
>> I love this, and it's what we
can provide with the best of
earth data and the best of
analytic solution.
this is a great solution.
>> that's exactly right.
>> so another question comes in
from Chris.
This is exciting.
What is Google's plans around
data management?
Does it have plans, Garrett
Gerrit, to expand our
multi-cloud approach to other
data management services?
>> Great question, Chris, and I
think it all starts from
recognizing basic fact.
For the majority of companies,
multi-cloud is a reality, and
when we talk about data silos,
we have to recognize that a
modern data silo and a
multi-cloud data silo, and at
big query omni, we wanted to
bring simplicity to multicloud,
which means that you can do
cross-cloud analytics, and we
are constantly evaluating which
of our data services makes sense
in an omni delivery, and
basically following our customer
scenarios where you are taking
us, too, and you can expect much
more to come in that direction.
>> This is great.
Really go forward with
multi-cloud as more and more
companies are using that as
their norm.
>> I think it's 90 percent of
the companies that we've
surveyed actually say that
multi-cloud for them is the
reality they are living in
today.
So let's place to that
complexity and deliver
multi-cloud across core
analytics.
>> Okay.
Good.
Thank you, Gerrit.
Next question comes in from Anon
at CVS health.
He asks this question to Leah,
actually.
Is there any map that reveals
all the services?
I think you might have shown
this at the tail end of the
demo, but maybe you could go
back and do sort of an overview
about the visualizations, the
capabilities of looker, how does
Looker and BigQuery play a role
with the visualizations for that
map of Earth Engine?
>> Awesome.
Yeah.
Thanks, Dane.
So basically, I think what this
question is asking is if you can
visualize the actual Samanthaic
mod
is he mantic moingdel that you'
creating in Looker, and actually
earlier this year, looker
launched the diagram which is
available in Looker's
marketplace, so you can directly
create a visualization of your
data model, whether your data is
in BigQuery, Spanner or other
places that are connected to
Looker, so check it out.
>> That's awesome.
Thank you, Leah.
The next question comes in
around our Cloud SQL and Cloud
spanner capabilities.
We offer both capabilities
today, as you know, Gerrit.
Which one is for which purpose?
Could you talk a little bit
about how spanSpanner is our --t
is your recommendation?
What use cases to use Cloud SQL,
as well as Cloud Spanner?
>> That is a great question,
because both of them, actually,
are pretty awesome services.
Cloud SQL is really a managed
service where you can decide
whether you want Postgres or my
SQL, and it's really for those
customers who want to leverage
basically perfect compatibility
with the my SQL ecosystem, use
all of the packages, use
everything around that type of
system.
And it's a really highly
reliable, high performance
managed service that we are
providing.
Spanner sits on the other end of
the spectrum, if you like.
Like it's a cloud native
database, it combines a unique
set of abilities.
It has five 9's of availability.
That is unheard of.
It has global consistency.
It's horizontally scaling.
All of the things that you want
to use when you're building
massively scaling global
applications.
And so if you are looking on
that spectrum, that's really
about scale, and yet, having
strong consistency, then Spanner
is the way to go.
And the good news is from
today's announcement, you can
use Spanner with a Postgres
interface, which means that you
don't need to relearn or take
another tool set chain in order
to work with it.
You can basically seamlessly
apply your Postgres skills and
go Cloud Native with Google
Cloud Spanner.
>> That's awesome.
Let me ask another question.
It's about a releour recent
partnership with Tableau.
This is a pretty exciting
partnership.
We've done a lot with them.
And could you talk a little bit
about how this strategy in this
partnership helps our Looker
customers specifically?
>> It is really about simplicity
and openness.
This announcement means that if
you are a Tableau customer, you
will be able to use looker's
semantic models and Looker for
tru
trusted governance, for high
performance database access.
If you are a Looker customer, it
means that you can add Tableau's
self service data visualization
right on to your Looker
scenario.
So the bottom line is that it
makes working with data more
simple.
It helps our customers who are
trying to find the right balance
between self service and
flexibility and strong
governance and semantics.
It really brings together the
best out of two worlds.
>> That's great.
And I think it's really a
reflection of our open strategy
for the data cloud.
Again, it brings more community,
more customers.
More use cases, more
capabilities that we can bring
as part of one ecosystem.
>> That's exactly right.
>> That's awesome.
>> The next question comes in
from Andrew.
It's -- another question
actually to Nakita about the
live demo we showed in
integration of Vertex AI.
How does this work with BigQuery
ML or BigQuery machine learning?
Nakita, could you take that
question?
>> Absolutely.
That's a great question.
So for those of you who don't
know what BigQuery ML is, it
allows you to I build and train
machine models with just a few
lines of SQL.
So in the demo we showed how you
can work Vertex AI workbench to
have access to essentially the
BigQuery console but from a
notebook interface, which I'm
super excited about.
So you could actually create and
train your ML models in SQL and
do all of this from the notebook
interface, but still have that
connection to BigQuery and be
able to use whatever Tableau
data you have stored in your
BigQuery.
>> Okay.
That's awesome.
Thank you, Nakita.
Next question comes in from
Jeff.
Another question on looker.
Could you talk a little bit
about how the Looker is enabling
these new sets of API-driven
experiences, specifically,
Jeff's asking, what are the
considerations that we should
have in place for the way we
integrate it with other tools
that we should be using?
Could you talk a little bit
about how we can now connect
with Sheets, so there's some new
things that we connect with with
Looker.
>> Hey, Jeff, awesome question,
and I do want to pre text it
with the following statement.
Looker is going to be a key
element of any data landscape.
Basically, what Looker is doing,
it's giving you two amazing
things.
One is it gives you a model
semantic layer, basically where
you can describe your data
landscape with very rich an
notations.
And this semantic layer is
connected directly to the
database system.
For instance, when it runs on
BigQuery, it completely
delegates all of the queries
right in to BigQuery so it
delivers stellar performance.
And Looker as a whole, has a
pretty amazing API-first
concept, which means that it is
so beyond AI, it allows you to
build data-rich applications.
It allows you to basically run
away to customer experience, to
internal applications and make
them really data rich.
And last but not least, you
know, it kind of gave it away
here, we are also integrating
more and more products with
looker semantic model.
For instance, we are adding
connected sheets as a way how
you can analyze and discover
data described in look ML.
So check it out.
It's going to make a big
difference in your landscape as
well.
>> This is great.
We are almost out of time, so
we're just going to take one
more question before wrapping
things up.
The last question is from
Ferard.
He talks about how at USDA, many
of the methods are using
different visualizations.
How does this complement our
strategy with how we're
connecting all this data.
It's over 50 petabytes of data.
How do we connect all that data
with Earth Engine and enable all
these different ways to process
it with all these different
tools.
>> Absolutely.
Hey, great question.
So first of all, it starts with
making sure that there is data,
and with Earth Engine, you get
this amazing data link of
satellite imagery and GIS data
available to you.
The second piece is that you
need to have a powerful
processing framework, and by the
integration to BigQuery, you can
use the most -- scale in the
fastest warehousing system on
this planet to analyze this data
alongside with all of the rest
of your data, of your business
data.
And last but not least, like you
said, it's about complete
openness.
The announcements that we have
shared today with Look ML allows
that you can connect top low,
connected sheets, all on top of
that right tool and make sure
that you are using the tool that
look like the most, but they
probably close it off, because I
think we are out of time.
Dane and I have a very important
message for all of you, and here
it goes.
>> Thanks to Gerrit, as well as
our friends over on the demo set
for answering some great
questions, and it's really been
awesome hearing from all of you.
Be sure to hop back over to the
next Web site.
Javier will share all the great
things happening with Google
Workspace.
Thanks so much for joining us.
>> Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google Cloud Next.
All right.
We've had a lot of great content
so far.
And I have to say I learned a
lot just now watching the data
Cloud session.
I hope you're ready for even
more.
I'm Javier Soltero, vice
president and general manager
for Google Workspace.
And I'm super excited to be with
you today.
Though, to be honest, I really
was hoping we could all be in
person by now.
Since flexibility is one of the
key themes for today, we'll
embrace what we have to work
with, even if we can't be
together.
Although the last 18 months have
been filled with uncertainty, we
continue to be inspired by
customers and users who found
new ways to create and stay
connected.
Driving innovation and embracing
change are always challenges for
every business, whether you're
ten people or 100,000.
The goal seems simple.
Empower your teams to work
effectively together, in part by
Enduring that your technology is
an enabler, not a blocker.
As we've evolved Google
Workspace, we've been focused on
helping individuals, teams and
entire organizations drive
innovation and greater impact
with the tools they use every
day.
And flexibility has been
foundational to our approach.
It's why we decided to not only
be Cloud first, but Cloud only.
It's why we've always
prioritized user choice.
It's why we take a zero trust
approach to security and why we
make sure any product innovation
we introduce is truly built for
everyone.
And those principles are core to
why our customers choose us.
Millions of companies, schools,
government agencies and other
organizations rely on Google
Workspace to help them navigate
whatever challenges they may
face.
They're also a big contributor
to our own continued success as
a business.
Google has run on what is now
Google Workspace for the last
15-plus years, and it's part of
why we have been able to
continue to innovate and adapt
as we've scaled.
In that time, we've grown to
over 144,000 employees, made 213
acquisitions, added dozens of
offices around the world and
more than quadrupled the number
of annual searches we support.
We've weathered changing market
conditions and user preferences
and competitive challenges, just
like any business, just like
your business.
One constant for us has always
been our tools, which were
designed to meet ever-shifting
needs and circumstances.
Today, we'll walk through some
of the most impactful
innovations in our tool set that
help unlock the full potential
of individuals, teams and
organizations in a flexible,
more effective hybrid workplace.
First, let's talk about
collaboration.
Effective team collaboration
powers creativity and
innovation.
It's how people work towards
shared goals, build team culture
and are able to achieve
substantially more than they
would on their own.
With everyone's time in such
high demand, and the explosion
of collaboration tools giving us
no shortage of ways to reach one
another and work together,
collaboration can often feel
fragmented.
Conversations and work flows
scattered across disparate
channels.
Now more than ever, the
technology you choose should
work intelligently and effective
across every medium to enable
collaboration wherever it
happens.
Last month, we introduced
Spaces, the central place for
flexible team collaboration in
Google Workspace.
Spaces are built to be tightly
integrated with Calendar, Drive,
Docs, Sheets, Slides, Meets and
tasks to provide a uniquely
better way for people to engage
in topic-based discussions,
share knowledge and ideas,
connect across organizational
boundaries and build team
culture.
All in the service of moving
projects forward.
In the same way that a group of
people can accomplish more by
working together, our integrated
experience is greater than the
sum of its parts, helping people
better collaborate and manage
their time and attention.
By thoughtfully bringing
together collaboration, surfaces
and channels, the goal is to
help people stop thinking about
where and focus instead on the
what.
To continue investing in this
area, we've been working with
customers to understand their
needs, especially the changing
circumstances we've all been
facing.
In line with feedback we've
gotten, we'll be adding in-line
topic threading, more powerful
Search, robust security and
admin tools for content
moderation, and discoverable
spaces.
We hope this makes it even
easier for organizations and
teams to both proactively share
and find the knowledge they need
to deliver greater impact.
Those of us working remotely
realized early on how crucial it
is to cultivate a sense of human
connection with our colleagues.
No matter where or how we work,
we all need to be seen, heard
and understood.
Towards that end, in the last 18
months, we've invested heavily
in bringing functionality to
Google Meet, that makes
connecting virtually almost as
natural and rewarding as
connecting in person.
This includes AI-powered noise
cancellation, low-light mode and
live translated captions, along
with a new intuitive user
interface, complete with polls,
Q&A and breakout rooms that help
make meetings more productive,
inclusive and immersive.
With all of these improvements,
we're seeing customers who
previously opted to use
third-party meeting solutions
reconsider moving to Google
Meet.
We've also invested in making
our tools reflect the new ways
people are working, to support
hybrid and distributed teams.
We've added the ability to set
working hours, work location and
recurring out of office
notifications from calendar.
We also introduced the ability
to RSVP to a meeting with a
virtual or in-person location.
All these investments are geared
toward helping people better
manage their time and ultimately
protect their well-being.
Well-being has been a central
focus for us at Google over the
past year, and for countless
organizations supporting their
employees during this long
period of remote work.
Two clear, bright spots we've
seen in pivoting to remote work
have been, one, an increase in
empathy for our co-workers'
lives outside the office, and
two, an increased focus in
collaboration equity, where the
ability for everyone to
participate equally and fully.
For more than a year, we've all
been reduced to digital video
tiles, and it's had a
democratizing effect on
meetings.
We thought a lot about how we
can sustain this equity as more
of us move into a hybrid model.
Next month, we're launching
companion mode, which offers a
unified experience for people in
the office and their remote
colleagues.
Those in the office can still
use the best of in-room audio
and video from Google-made
hardware, but they can also join
the meeting using companion mode
on their laptop.
This lets them fully participate
in the meeting with access to
chat, white boarding, Q&A and
polls, along with the ability to
share content, just as they
would from home.
We think it's imperative to
provide one unified meeting
experience regardless of where
and how people connect.
And as more people head back in
to shared physical spaces, we're
enhancing our meetings hardware
to give organizations greater
choice and flexibility.
We have two new all-in-one video
conferencing devices, the Google
Meet Series 1 Desk 27 and Board
65, with new standards of audio,
video and white boarding
capabilities built in.
These devices can turn any room
or shared space into a
collaboration hub.
We also have new third-party
devices coming to the Google
Meet ecosystem, including this
Logitech rally bar, and this new
Rayz Rally Pro Speaker doc, that
will automatically launch Google
Meet for video meetings and
provide an improved audio
experience from a mobile device.
Lastly, we're partnering with
Cisco to bring interoperability
between our video conferencing
devices, so you'll be able to
launch a Google meeting on WebEx
devices and WebEx meetings on
Google Meet hardware.
This sort of partnership is
crucial in delivering on our
vision of Google Workspace for
everyone.
Last year, our focus was on
introducing an integrated
experience across our
first-party products.
This year, we're prioritizing
strengthening the platform that
supports and extends them.
This is so important, because
our success is measured not only
by how people use and love our
products, but by the ecosystem
that thrives around them.
And what we're seeing in the
numbers here is remarkable.
Google Workspace has more than 3
billion users and a stunning 4.8
billion apps have been installed
in Google Workspace to date.
There are more than 5,300 public
apps available in the Google
Workspace Marketplace, plus
thousands more private apps that
customers have built for
themselves.
It really shows what's possible
when you combine great ideas,
easy-to-use APIs and the ability
to reach a user base that's 3
billion strong.
While users and developers have
been able to build on apps like
Gmail, Drive and Docs for years,
we're now in the process of
making it just as easy to
integrate with Chat, Spaces and
Meet.
If Google Workspace is how it's
done, then the Google Workspace
platform is how it's integrated.
Miro has already announced their
plans for integrating in Google
Meet, and today we're pleased to
announce a new integration for
Chat and Spaces from Atlassian.
Joining me now to share more,
please welcome Atlassian's Chief
Product Officer, Joff Redfern.
Hey, Joff.
Great to have you with us.
>> Thanks for having me.
I'm delighted to be here.
>> You know, for those that
aren't familiar with Atlassian,
can you tell us a little bit
more about it?
>> Absolutely.
At Atlassian, our mission is to
unleash the potential of every
team.
Our team collaboration and
productivity software helps
teams organize, discuss and
complete shared work.
But at the same time, we believe
there's no one tool to solve all
of the complexity of teamwork
and collaboration.
Every team is unique.
Each team is its own snow flake,
and they should be able to use
the best tools for the job.
We focus on building the best in
class collaboration solutions,
and then deeply integrating it
with all the other tools that
teams need to get things done.
>> You know, it's so true that
the nature of every role in team
within an organization, and the
challenges they face, are
unique.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about the opportunity that
Atlassian sees in building for
Google Workspace and how you got
started?
>> Yeah.
Today, Atlassian solutions
already extend and connect with
thousands of tools from
collaboration, chat,
security,devops and a whole lot
more, and we're excited to
continue to extend our
partnership with Google
Workspace to deliver for our
joint customers.
Work is everywhere, people's
chat, in inboxes.
It's all flooded with work.
And to help turn that clutter in
to progress, we believe in
integrating Trello and Jira and
our other tools everywhere work
is.
The better together integration
helps Atlassian and Google
customers make work flow across
their organization.
Rich content and easy actions
help move work forward.
In fact, we are Workspace
customers, and this is what led
us to dream up our initial
integrations.
One of our first launches
together was the Trello
segregation in Gmail, and that
was back in 2017.
Today, more than seven million
people have installed it, which
is really impressive.
>> That's awesome.
Today, we're so excited to
announce the new Jira bot that
connects to Google Chat and to
Spaces and enables users to
create issues, monitor them, all
within the space that you are
already using for collaboration.
>> Well, Workspace is unique in
that it offers such a
significant opportunity to reach
over three billion users.
And today, Atlassian and Google
have invested in a number of
Workspace products to help users
work better together, whether
that's unfurling Google Drive
links across Atlassian products,
embedding an important Google
Doc in Jira work management or
creating new Trello cards from
Gmail.
But there's more.
And we'll continue to listen to
our customers and then follow
their needs.
>> It's great to see the power
of Jira built in to Chat and to
Spaces.
It's such a powerful example of
how developers can build new
experiences from across the
platform, from Gmail to Chat to
Spaces to drive.
Thanks, Joff.
Really excited to have you here
with us, and I'm very excited to
continue to develop our
partnership.
>> Thanks, Javier.
Have a great show.
>> As we work with Atlassian and
All our partners to build
and deliver new experiences,
rest assured that every one of
them is designed with security
in mind.
Starting with a zero trust
approach to identity in Google
Workspace.
We also employ a rigorous
vetting process to ensure
partner apps are secure before
becoming available in the Google
Workspace Marketplace.
Finally, we recognize that it's
not always developers, but the
person closest to the problem
who best understands how to make
work more efficient and
impactful.
To better empower these users,
we're providing them access to
custom, no-code Appsheet apps
right from Gmail with dynamic
E-mail.
This lets users interact to data
directly and securely from their
inbox to get things done in
powerful new ways.
This experience is available
today and you'll see it in
action in the upcoming demo in a
few minutes.
Now, we've talked about the
powerful new experiences in
Google Workspace, and the
platform that surrounds it, but
neither of those can transform
the way your organization works
without a broader foundation for
security.
We've seen too many headlines
lately about data and security
breaches, and it's a powerful
reminder that modern
collaboration requires modern
security.
Legacy collaboration tools were
built for a by-gone era and
these headlines make it clear
that a band-aid approach to a
security problem with legacy
tools just doesn't cut it.
We built Google Workspace with
modern collaboration and
security in mind to keep your
people and your data safe.
Let's talk about what makes
Google's approach unique.
First, because we're cloud-only,
we don't have the same
vulnerabilities that legacy
collaboration tools and
infrastructure have.
With Google Workspace, there's
no need for thick client
applications, E-mail attachments
or on-prem identity directories.
Each of which provide bad actors
with too many opportunities for
attack.
And all our security protections
are included with Google
Workspace, which means you don't
need to spend money on security
add-ons, and you're less
susceptible to supply chain
attacks.
Second, our entire platform is
built on the BeyondCorp security
model, which is Google's unique
approach to Zero Trust.
This lets employees work
securely from anywhere on any
device without the need for a
clunky VPN.
Finally, we're best in class at
automatically detecting and
preventing attacks, from
phishing to malware to supply
chain to ransomware.
Every day, we block 15 billion
spam messages, 100 million
phishing attempts and 3 million
deceitful URL's from reaching
our customers.
All of this comes together to
provide Google Workspace
customers with the most trusted
way to connect, create and
collaborate.
All right.
Now how are we working to
enhance that security vision
even further?
Well, I'm excited to announce
some new capabilities that build
on this unique approach to
security.
First, we've already made
client-side encryption available
in beta for Drive, Docs, Sheets
and Slides, and now we're
bringing it to Google Meet as
well.
Client-side encryption gives our
customers complete control over
the privacy and confidentiality
of their data.
Next, we're introducing data
loss prevention for chat.
You can think of this as part of
our promise to enable
collaboration without compromise
when it comes to security.
With data loss prevention in
chat, you can support
spontaneous conversation while
preventing sensitive and
confidential information from
leaking outside of your
organization.
Admins can control what users
share inside and outside their
domain on Google Chat, and
they're alerted about any
violations.
Finally, I'm excited to share
the Drive labels is now
generally available.
This gives organizations the
ability to classify files stored
in Drive based on their
sensitivity level.
Labels also integrates with
Google Vault, and Google
Workspace data loss prevention
to prevent external sharing,
downloading and printing of
sensitive files.
Just another example of how
Google Workspace enables
collaboration while providing
the right controls to manage
access and protect data.
So we've talked you through a
lot today, and the common thread
is that we're continuing to
build a modern productivity
solution.
One that seamlessly brings
together the right tools in the
right way to help you more
effectively collaborate, that
supports hybrid and distributed
work and that lets you extend
and customize solutions for your
organization.
And of course, one that's secure
by design.
It's a platform that helps you
unlock the full potential within
your organization so that you
can innovate, even thrive, amid
the disruptions of today and
tomorrow.
There will always be certain
things that are out of our
control, but with the right
people and tools in place, as
we've seen firsthand with our
customers, we can always be
prepared to effectively adapt,
no matter what comes next.
Though in this case, it just so
happens that I actually know
what's coming next, and it's our
demo with Eric Troutman,
Director of Product Management
for Google Workspace.
Stay tuned to see what we just
talked about come to life.
>> Hello, everyone!
I'm Erica troutman, product
director for Google Workspace.
There has been a ton of
innovation in Workspace this
past year, and in the next 15
minutes, I get to share with you
all the progress we've made,
helping teams of all sizes to
connect, create and collaborate.
This demo has two parts.
In the first, I'll be showing
you Workspace in action through
a little story that we've
created, and then I'll hand it
off to my colleague, Matt, who
will show you all the ways
developers with build on the
Workspace platform.
And as a reminder, before we get
started, this is truly a live
session, so you never know
what's going to happen.
If you haven't already, click
the button that says, "join the
interactive experience" on the
next Web site, and then we'll
see you in the live room where
you can interact with chats and
do fun stuff like take polls,
which we're going to try out
right now.
How many employees have you or
your company onboarded virtually
this year?
Let us know in the poll below.
Under 10?
11 to 25, 26 to 50 or more than
50?
I know that for me, recruiting
and getting people in the door,
that got harder during the start
of the pandemic, taking that
brand new person that you worked
so hard to find, bringing them
up to speed, making them feel
like they're part of the team,
and really enabling them to do
great work, those critical first
few weeks on the job.
And of course, it is so
overwhelming to be that new
hire.
You're learning not just the
role, but the tools, the
processes, the people, and the
culture, maybe remotely.
So I want to show you how
Workspace is making this easier.
Please meet our hero, Pablo.
He is in exactly this position.
He's about to receive an offer
letter from his dream employer,
Symbol Manufacturing, which, by
the way, is not a real company,
in case you were wondering, so
don't go look it up.
His hiring manager Allison is
going to help onboard him at the
company.
Allison is really, really
excited to get Pablo on board
and there are a ton of steps in
the process that she's going to
help him through, so we'll show
you how she uses Workspace to
help streamline that experience
for bochl both of them, even
when it requires using third
party software or custom tools,
the symbol team built within
Workspace.
The point here, as Javier
mentioned, is that Workspace is
a platform that brings together
the right tools in the right way
at the right time, whether those
tools are built by Google or
someone else.
Okay.
Before we get back to Pablo and
Allison's story, let's see what
you've been experiencing here in
the poll.
Wow, it looks like 48 percent of
you say that you've onboarded
more than 15 people this year,
that is a lot, so I think you
are going to be able to relate
to Allison.
When you were recruiting and
onboarding, what was the first
thing you did?
I think probably you sent them
an offer letter, and fingers
crossed, hoped they signed it.
Allison uses the Docusign
integration in Google docs to do
just that.
So here you see Pablo is going
to check his personal G mail.
On his mobile phone.
And oh, he just scrolled past
it.
There's an offer letter in
there.
He's going to click on that and
open up Docusign within the
E-mail.
He clicks the nice cover letter
Allison has sent him, clicks to
open the document itself.
Okay.
Great.
Start date is right.
They spelled his name right.
Salary is what they talked
about.
I think he's going to accept.
He signs the offer letter with
his finger right there on his
phone without leaving G mail.
Come on, Pablo, sign!
Sign!
And he signs and clicks submit,
and Allison is so relieved.
In other systems, Pablo might
have had to stop what he was
doing, open another tab to
review and sign the agreement,
go back to G mail, hopefully
remember where he left off.
It's just unnecessarily
disruptive if you're signing a
single contract.
But if you're someone who
reviews and signs contracts all
the time, it's incredibly
onerous.
So deep integrations with
leading third-party apps like
DocuSign save you valuable time
and keep you focused on your
core job.
Audience, if you have any
favorite Google Workspace
integrations, we would love it
if you would share those in the
comments because it's a great
way to help everyone who's out
there -- everyone who's there
discover the best of what's out
there.
All right.
Back at Symbol, when Pablo
returned his offer letter, that
kicked off the onboarding
process.
So let's see what happens next.
Pablo's now at home, on his
personal G mail, and he sees an
E-mail from Allison come in at
the top there.
He opens it and notices, hmmm,
this is not a typical E-mail.
This is an Appsheet dynamic
E-mail, which allows him to
interact with the forum without
ever leaving his in box, so he's
selecting his laptop, accessory
type, desk type, T-shirt size,
really important, he enters his
address, clicks submit, and just
like that, Cymbal can now send
him his stuff.
This is especially important
because Pablo is going to work
remotely initially.
Just like with the DocuSign
example, the dynamic E-mail lets
him complete his tasks where he
is, in G mail, saving him the
time and hassle of toggling back
and forth between tabs and apps,
just to fill out a form.
And, by the way, throughout any
of this, if you have questions
regarding dynamic E-mails or
Appsheet, please comment below
so that we can address them in
the Q&A.
Let's fast forward to Pablo's
first day on the job.
He's received his equipment.
He's excited to work.
He's in calendar and notices,
ooh, he's got a one-on-one with
Allison coming up.
He's going to click on that
calendar invite.
And join the meeting with
Allison.
Allison welcomes him to Cymbal,
offers to give him a short
overview of calendar and meet.
So here she's showing him how to
set up his working location and
working hours so that his
colleagues, who are global, know
when he's available and when
he's off.
Features like these only
available in Google Workspace,
really improve employee
well-being and overall job
satisfaction.
They help employees better
coordinate how and when to work
together, enduring both
productivity and time to
recharge, even though our
offices might be in our bedrooms
or our kitchens.
Honestly, Pablo is going to
spend a lot of time in meetings.
So Allison shows him all the
great new features that have
been added to Meet over the past
year.
The interface is new, and easier
to use.
Here she's showing him how to
get into some of the advanced
features.
He's definitely going to want to
turn on noise cancellation,
which is great for filtering out
dogs barking or neighborhood
construction.
And if you're having trouble
hearing someone, you can just
click on the closed caption
button to follow along in live
captions, even in a different
language than what's being
spoken, which blows my mind.
AI powered translated captions
in meetings are launching soon,
and only Google Workspace offers
this built-in for everyone.
There's also a host of new
features which she's showing him
here to boost engagement.
So Chat, Polls, these magical
little breakout rooms that she's
going to show that transport you
to smaller groups where you can
brain storm, white boards,
integrations with Google Docs.
At this point, the one-on-one
wraps up, and Allison suggests
he goes into G mail and start
exploring the spaces he's been
added to.
We recently launched Spaces,
which are the evolution of rooms
in Google Chat, and they're the
central place for team
collaboration in Google
Workspace.
Pablo looks at the team space
and notices his team has written
him a bunch of welcome messages,
which is really great.
He responds.
And now he's going to browse the
spaces that are available to
him, and he discovers one
particularly relevant to his
work, quality inspectoInspectors
North America.
Awesome.
That's him.
In this space, he can connect
with his colleagues, discuss
ideas and collaborate on
projects easily.
Spaces are unique in that
they're tightly integrated with
the entire Google Workspace
product set.
So calendar, drive, docDocs, Shs
and Slides, meetsMeets and Task
bringing all the tools you need
to engage in topic-based
discussions, share knowledge and
ideas, move projects forward,
and build communities and team
culture.
Pablo notices there's a little
bubble with Allison's image,
which means she sent him a
direct message.
Turns out this is Pablo's first
project, and Allison shared a
document with him, which we can
see in the preview here.
Pablo opens the document, and
notices his co-workers already
pre populated some of the core
information.
So facilities, number of workers
per facility on the floor and
types of tasks that they per
m
perform.
Pablo's job is to optimize the
process that managers use to
create tickets and send them to
their quality inspectors on the
front line.
Okay.
To do this at his prior company,
Pablo would have needed to
secure IT assistance at a
minimum, and more probably a
contractor and probably a budget
to go build an app.
So not fast, not easy.
Instead, Pablo's going to Use
Appsheet.
He connects his sheet To
Appsheet, and after about an
hour of customization, he's
created a quality inspection app
that his team can use.
So he opens it up to file his
first ticket to one of his
quality inspectors.
Now what?
All right.
Over on the manufacturing floor,
we meet Adu, a quality inspector
reporting to Pablo, and he's
just received a pop-up
notification on his phone with
the inspection ticket Pablo
assigned to him.
So he pulls up the Appsheet app
that Pablo created and performs
the inspection.
He's going to take a picture of
the completed job.
Let's see if he -- we can get
him over there in to the
Appsheet app.
He noticed -- yeah, there we go.
All right.
He's now in the app.
And he's going to take a picture
of the job once it's completed.
He's going to annotate that, and
submit it as closed, and that,
then, will notify Pablo on
Pablo's side of the app.
So hopefully you saw how easy
that was to make collaboration
more efficient between an office
and front-line worker.
He used a really simple but
powerful Appsheet app to
eliminate the whole back and
forth between E-mails and chats
and then maybe switching to an
external ticketing system, and
then more E-mails and more app
-- more chatting.
At this point, if any of you can
think of useful -- for Appsheet
in your organization, please
share those with us in the form
below.
So think about all of those
repetitive tasks that make you
crazy day to day.
Those are the kind of things
that app sheets can automate for
you.
All right.
Back to Pablo.
Let's see if we're -- okay.
Still on Appsheet here for just
a quick second.
We're going to get back to
Pablo's day-to-day in his first
week on the job any moment here.
Let's see.
I'm looking here.
You guys have some really
interesting -- oh, scrolling
through here.
Asana, people like that
integration.
I saw people use hello sign.
That stuff is all fantastic.
All right.
Are we back to Pablo?
We're back to Pablo.
Back to Pablo.
It's the end of his first week
on the job.
He pulls up calendar in the side
bar while in G mail, and he
notices he should be joining the
team meeting.
So he clicks to join.
On the call, Allison introduces
Pablo to everyone and asks him
to share his reflections on his
first week.
And he is really proud of the
app that he built in Appsheet,
especially since this is a tool
the entire team can adopt.
He shows how easy it is to
create requests, assign one to
an inspector, follow the status.
He also pulls up the request
that he sent to Adu that was
already completed.
And if Pablo were joining from a
conference room, because
hopefully some day he will, he
can use companion mode, a
feature that's only available in
Google Meet to seamlessly join
and share from his laptop while
using in-room audio and video.
And with some congratulatory
emojis from his colleagues,
Allison closes off the meeting,
and the weekend can begin.
I think it's fair to say that
Pablo helped us with quite a lot
of demos in his first week on
the job, so thank you, Pablo.
And I hope that you can see how
at every turn Google Workspace
helps people connect and
collaborate to get more done
with an intuitive and integrated
set of tools.
With that, I'd like to introduce
my colleague, Matt, who's going
to take us under the hood and
talk about how you can build on
the work space platform.
>> Thanks, Erica.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Matthew, and I'm lead
product for the Google Workspace
platform.
Under that hood is a powerful
engine.
Let's talk about how you can
take advantage and build on the
Workspace platform.
As Javier mentioned, more than
4.8 billion apps have been
installed in Workspace to date.
This stunning number illustrates
Workspace is more than a hunt
for work, it's a powerful
enabler work flows.
The opportunity to build on the
Workspace platform is massive.
Nearly half the world's
population is already using
Workspace.
That's a huge audience.
Whether you want to grow an
existing business app or build
an entirely new business on the
platform.
To help you build experiences to
reach these 3 billion users, we
delivered a range of tools so
you can innovate, from no quote
options like Appsheet, as Erica
discovered, to powerful
scripting with app script, to a
complete set of easy-to-use
API's.
And we've been listening to your
feedback.
Developers want to use their own
preferred language in tools when
building integrations like
Workspace add-ones or shoutouts,
or even using our large
collection of rest API's.
So we've opened up the platform
to support development with any
tools, any language, on any
public cloud.
Of course, if you're using
Google Cloud, why wouldn't you?
Take advantage of Cloud Run,
cloud Data Store and cloud AI to
power your app.
So there's a big opportunity to
build on the Workspace platform,
with the tools and languages of
your choice.
Now let's take a look at how the
process works across the three
core stages of app development,
the design, develop and publish
phases of your app.
Starting with the design phase,
we have created the card builder
tool.
This tool allows you to lay out
the visual design and user
experience of your app.
There are a range of templates,
and you can also drag and drop
components of the app around,
li.
But for more davensd developers,
you also have the ability to see
the code in the editor, and make
updates there as well.
As we move on to the develop
phase, you now have a range of
language and tooling to choose
from, whether using options from
Google like app script, or your
own preferred language and
tooling.
While App Script is a great
option for developers, we have
invested in and extended the
Google Workspace platform to
embrace a wider range of
industry-standard tools, so
developers can use their own
text stack and reuse their
existing code when building for
Workspace.
When your integration is
complete, congratulations!
You're ready to publish it.
For public use in the Workspace
marketplace, where it will be
available for billions of users.
It's worth noting that there are
more than 5,300 publicly
available apps in the
marketplace today.
This number really highlights
the diversity of use cases and
remarkable opportunity for
developers in building for
Workspace.
And of course if you're
developing a custom app for use
in your own organization, you
have the ability to publish that
app privately so it remains
exclusively for the use of your
organization.
So there you have it.
A quick tour of how you design,
develop and publish new
integrations for Workspace.
Now let's hear from you, what
Workspace platform technologies
are you curious to learn more
about throughout the conference?
Is it developer tools and
languages?
Like app script orScript Or App
Or maybe it's product
integrations through add-ons or
shoutouts.
Or perhaps data API's or data
access through Workspace API's.
But that's enough about the
technology platform.
Why don't we take a look at a
few real world examples of
integrations developer work
space, and let's start with the
copper CRM add-on for G mail.
Copper identified a problem.
Workspace users needed a simple
but powerful CRM solution that
is built to work for apps and
Workspace.
So naturally, they built the
solution.
Here you can see it in action,
as a sales rep receives an
E-mail from a customer.
The copper add-on detects the
E-mail.
After installation, the copper
add-on will detect the E-mail
and pull up the customer
information automatically.
But the customer's information
right next to their E-mail, so
we click through the
installation, we will eventually
get to -- there we are.
As you can see, the cop eper
add-on has detected the E-mail
and pulled up --
With the customer's information
right next to their E-mail, the
sales rep has all the insight
they need from copper, and can
craft the best response to the
customer.
All without leaving G mail.
Copper is a perfect example of
business that has grown
alongside Workspace, and today,
100 percent, yes, that's
correct, all of their business
comes from Workspace customers,
these are customers who value a
best-in-class solution with
deep, native integration to
critical Workspace apps, such as
G mail, Drive and Calendar.
The opportunity to build for the
Workspace platform spans
multiple surface areas.
So let's take a look at how this
looks in chat andChat and Space
the brand new Jira bot from
Atlassian.
Here, you can see a customer
service rep jumping into the
customer success chat space to
report an issue with a customer.
After a short discussion in the
space, the rep creates an issue
in Jira, via the Jira bot.
Every time there's a status
update on the case, the Jira bot
will update the team members in
the chat.
This saves the entire team
valuable time they might have
spent going back and forth to
Jira, and check updates.
It also helps the team focus on
collaborating together to help
the customer instead of
navigating their tools.
We would love to hear what
Workspace integration, or apps
you're using or would like to
see.
Please share in the comments so
that the community hears what
are some of the best.
These are just a few examples of
how developers are innovating in
Workspace, and driving business
value for themselves and their
customers.
We can't wait to see what you
create and innovate on
Workspace, whether it's a
notebook app or a professionally
developed solution.
Either way, we've provided a
rich canvas here for you to
start with and believe the best
is yet to come.
So look at the chat.
It looks like you're excited to
get going and ready to get
started.
Visit
developers.Google.com/Workspace
to learn more about integrating
with Workspace.
>> Thanks to my colleague, Matt,
for taking us under the hood
with Workspace today, and a
special thanks to you, our
audience, for your engagement.
We love seeing your comments on
Chat.
Now stay tuned for our live Q&A,
covering everything from our
spotlight and this demo.
Thank you so much!
We'll see you soon!
>> All right.
So we want to hear what's your
role at work?
Do you work in the IT
department?
Are you a developer?
Are you a person who uses
Workspace just in the process of
your daily work, or something
else entirely?
Let us know in the chat.
Lr
All right, Javier, while we wait
for those results, why don't you
answer a question for us.
>> Let's do it.
>> Tell us, what are you most
excited about in Workspace these
days?
>> Well, I'm excited about the
pace at which we're delivering
some amazing new capabilities
for people.
But I'm most excited about the
way we're bringing the Workspace
products closer together and
helping people be that much more
effective at getting their work
done, collaborating with their
colle
colleagues, building documents,
basically coming -- translating
ideas and turning them in to
reality by using our products.
It's very exciting and we can't
wait for all the stuff that
we're going to come out with
this year and next.
>> Absolutely.
And I feel like, as I've seen
the chats coming in, customers
are talking about examples of
how they're using Workspace, how
they're going to use some of the
new Appsheet innovation in G
mail, so it's really exciting.
Okay.
Our poll results have come back
in, and it looks like, do you
want to read the results?
>> Yeah.
Well, it looks like we have
pretty even split between our IT
folks and developers, which is
great and consistent with, like,
one of the key -- there's a lot
of great content for all of you
at Next, and then we also have a
healthy portion of end users and
other folks.
So widening the audience, trying
to make this a highly relevant
topic for a lot of people.
Not just technology
professionals.
People use this every day, so
I'm excited so see this many
people.
>> Absolutely.
All right.
Let's jump in with our first
question.
>> Let's do it.
>> It comes from Lucy, who says
I saw the news about the new
Work Safer Program.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about that?
>> Sure.
Thank you for the question,
Lucy.
So we're announcing Work Safer
as a way to bring the best of
Google Workspace and from Google
Cloud Security together to help
companies rise to the growing
threat of cybersecuritiness
accid
incidents, et cetera.
So it brings together Google
Workspace with some exciting
innovation from our security
team and from those customers
that have broader, more diverse
environments, we've partnered
with two of the best names in
the security business, Palo Alto
networks and cloCloud Strike to
provide a complete solution for
these companies to remain secure
in a much more challenging
environment.
>> That's great.
That's great to hear.
Kind of an all-in-1 solution.
All right.
Let's move on to question number
2.
And this one is going to be for
Erica.
And it comes from Michael who
asks, is it hard to collaborate
if members are using different
platforms to join?
For example, he's running off of
Google's tool set that has a
partner who's using a different
platform.
>> Yeah.
This is a really important
question, Michael, thank you for
that.
I think the reality is that we
live in a world where there's
different different sets of
products that you or your
partners or your customers are
going to be using, and it's
fundamental to, you know, our
way of viewing the world that
Workspace should not be a wild
garden.
It should interstgrate.
It should connect and make those
tasks easier for you.
So on the Drive Doc Sheets side,
we invest really deeply in
making interoperability with
Microsoft in particular, totally
seamless, and very easy to use.
So, for example, you can open up
Microsoft documents in the
Google editor and have the full
interactive experience.
Those changes will be saved back
to your Microsoft document,
including comments.
All of those changes are updated
in real time.
But there's also a really
important third party co
compatibility component, which I
would love for my colleague,
Matt, to discuss.
>> Yeah.
It's fundamental to us, that
whether using tools which
interoperate with the Workspace
sui
suite, or things that complement
the types of functionality that
we offer, that these all work
together.
I'll take one example.
We recently announced our new
partnership with Miro, which
does virtual white boarding or
collaborative canvassing, and
you can imagine that as you're
working with that tool set, not
only are you building things on
your canvas, but you're
scheduling meetings, you're
holding meetings at which you
want to collaborate in real time
while changing things within
that tool.
And so what we are doing is
making it really easy for you to
schedule a meeting in calendar,
join a meeting in meet, at the
same time be working in your
Miro white board.
So yes, we believe very strongly
that all these things should
work better together.
Workspace and partners, a really
great experience for our
customers and users.
>> That's great.
Thank you.
All right.
Our next question comes from
Bambang, who's with Chandra
Osrey and asks must we have or
use G mail or company E-mail for
using the rest of Google Cloud
and Workspace?
I think Erica, this is probably
one for you.
>> Sure.
Yeah.
Happy to take that.
We have tailored offerings that
don't require you to migrate
E-mail.
So Workspace essentials is
perfect for that.
It includes the Workspace
product set, but without E-mail,
so it integrates easily, and we
also have deep interoperability
with Outlook and Calendar.
>> Got it.
Great.
Javier, we're going to move to
you next, and the question comes
from Hannah, and Hannah says
that her team loves new
features, like being able to
jump right in to a Meet from a
Doc, and is wondering, will
integrations like that be
extended to other apps inside
Workspace?
>> Yes.
In fact, we're very excited to
continue to advance the
opportunity of bringing, you
know, to start, actually, from
the real-time collaborative
experience that Google Docs pine
neared, now I think 15 years
ago, I believe yesterday was our
15th birthday.
One more and we can drive, and
be able to allow users to go
from working in real time with
others in a document to easily
getting into a live video feed
where you can hear and see each
oth
other.
And so that progression, I
guess, is a really important
part of enduring seamless
collaboration, and it applies,
we see, to both our own editors,
as well as, as Matt mentioned,
third parties over time.
>> Yeah.
Got it.
>> Makes sense.
Well, we're going to stay with
you, Javier, for this next
question, which comes from
Carter, who says my company uses
a lot of point solutions like
Zoom and slack, in addition to
having Microsoft and Google
licenses.
So what would you say is the
argument for consolidating?
>> Well, look, one of the
strongest aspects of Google
Workspace is the element of
choice, the choice that users
make, billions of users have
made to select individual
products for key roles in their
lives, at work, et cetera.
And so we're guided as we refine
these products by that sense of
affinity that people have to the
approach that we bring.
That approach is best expressed
and nurtured, I think, through
deeper and interintegration
between our products to create
something that's ultimately new,
and at the same time we
recognize that there are other
companies around us in this
vibrant ecosystem of ours that
offer different points of view
and different aspects of what we
also provide, and we believe
that there's ample opportunity
for users to make an informed
choice and really recognize,
comes down to familiarity with
the products, the sense of
security that you get from an
integrated solution, and
ultimately the cost.
So it's a choice everyone makes,
and over time, we feel really
good about the continued growth
of our ecosystem.
>> That's great.
That's great.
Thank you.
Erica, we're coming back to you
with a question from Miles, who
asks, how do you plan to win
over die-hard fans of Excel and
other Microsoft creaCreation to
>> All right.
A good, challenging question
from Miles.
Well, as Javier said, we
introduced Docs and Sheets about
15 years ago, and that
fundamentally rethought what a
file should be.
Our belief is that these
experiences need to leverage the
best that the internet has to
offer.
So inter actiactivity, connecti
and data.
And they shouldn't just be a
physical -- a digital
representation of a physical
piece of paper that lives on
your hard drive.
And that's in stark contrast to
the mental model that, you know,
Legacy Solutions have evolved
from.
Over the years, we've invested a
ton in user experience and
making this incredibly easier to
adopt.
And the great thing about all of
this ease of use which billions
of people take advantage of,
which is has Google Security,
you know, enmeshed in
underpinning the whole
experience.
I would call out a couple of
features that I hope people are
aware of but if they're not,
they should be.
So Connected Sheets, for
example, if you weren't aware,
allows Sheets users to analyze
billions of rows of data, yes,
billions, in a single sheet, so
that really pushes the envelope
for what a productivity tool can
do, and our innovation around
Smart Canvas, which really super
charges interactivity,
intelligence and connection to
rich data in the form of these
modular building blocks that
transcend the file boundaries.
So we bring in smart chips that
bring rich information about
people, events, files,
templates.
We have tables and task lists.
All of that really further
enhances what these files should
be.
So what I would say is for any
of the die-hard Microsoft fans,
we would love to give you a
tour, and I bet we could change
your mind.
>> Got it.
Great.
Thanks, Erica.
All right, Javier, we're coming
to you next with a question from
Juliet, who comments that there
have been a lot of security
breaches lately in the news, and
what are we doing from a
Workspace perspective to protect
customers from these sorts of
attacks?
>> Well, look, it's a great
question, and thank you for the
ques
question.
A lot of these attacks originate
from the architecture and habits
that went along with legacy
products, right?
The sharing models, the approach
for storing content, a reliance
on heavy, powerful clients that
store a lot of information
locally on them, but don't
necessarily provide the best
degree of security.
Google Workspace was born in a
different era, and has had,
since the very beginning, a
different point of view about
the design and the approach to
security, and it comes, I guess,
as part of us being cloud only,
right?
Like, we grew up, and were
archi
architected for the distributed
world in which we live in now,
and it is the reason behind why
our products are so effective.
So we've continued to invest
around that to make it even
clearer how, along with
enhancements and innovative
capabilities from Google Cloud
Security, like BeyondCorp, et
cetera, we establish a
completely different model for
securing content while ensuring
the absolute best and most
effective level of collaboration
within a company, and beyond a
company, so externally with
other third parties, et cetera,
in partners.
>> Absolutely.
So it's really architected to be
safe in this world.
>> Yes.
Yes.
And actually, look, you
mentioned this idea of habits,
right?
Like, these -- the notion of
attachments, right, like the
model that people grew up with,
you know, when productivity
tools, digital productivity
tools were first introduced, is
the main vector through which a
lot of these ransomware and
other terrible things tend to
start, right?
Somebody, you know, either opens
an E-mail, like a phishing
attempt, or a malicious
attachment, something that gets
spread through, you know,
various different tools that
people are used to using, and
companies are really desperate
to say how did we actually put a
stop to this, and by the way,
can we do that in a way that
actually works us towards a
sense of transformation in our
company.
So it's not just about securing
your communication and
collaboration, but ultimately
taking that full opportunity to
make it more effective at the
same time.
So it's pretty exciting.
>> Yeah, it is exciting.
And, you know, you have been
working in this space for so
long.
You mentioned the legacy tools,
and, you know, from -- to work
at different companies, you've
been so focused on the
productivity market.
What have you learned across
those different experiences and
different products that is most
important, and the knowledge
that you use today?
>> Well, listen, I think the
most honest answer to that
question, and it may surprise
some of you, is you can't please
everybody, right?
You're building products that
play these very crucial roles in
people's personal lives, at
school, at work, and part of
their power is that they are
horizontal in nature.
They allow people -- they're
canvass for creation,
articulation of ideas, et
cetera.
And so you have to be very
careful and deliberate about the
process you use to evolve those
products.
And so as I mentioned earlier,
you know, we began our journey
as Google and the collaboration
space in a very particular point
in time, where it allowed us to
have a different point of view,
a more modern approach, and an
eye towards simplicity that
didn't undermine the
sophistication and power of the
products that we were doing.
That's what we are really
strongest at.
And so as a result, the task of
evolving those opinions in
products like Docs Or Sheets or
G mail or Meet, any one of these
products, they are the
representation of a point of
view that Google is bringing
that customers are actually
infor
informing, and helping us refine
over time, but it ultimately
requires that we really
understand what it is that we
believe the right result is for
our customers, and that may
mean, in some cases, that these
products are uniquely powerful
for key scenarios, and are not
necessarily just like something
that can be used for -- they're
not multi-tools, right?
>> Absolutely.
>> So it's a really exciting and
challenging journey for us.
>> Absolutely.
And having that strong point of
view, it's a great opportunity
to get feedback from all the
customers who are living --
listening now.
Please, share your feedback in
the chat.
We want to hear from you.
All right.
We have another question, it's
coming in from John, and it's
going to be for Matt, and John
asks, what are you doing to
encourage developers and ISV's
to build for Workspace?
>> Yeah.
Thanks for asking the question.
I know we talk a lot about
customers and users, but at the
heart of a successful platform
is developers, and so what makes
the developer want to build on
the platform?
Let's start with our open
philosophy.
Google as a company, for a long
time, has believed in the
openness of data, the openness
of access to platform, and that
extends to work space.
We built an extensive set of
API's and frameworks, and they
are completely open.
You can go build something
today, right now.
Second is reach.
If you are building something on
a platform, you want an
audience, right?
You want to build a business on
a platform, you want to have
success, your customers have
success, and we have -- or
Workspace certainly has a lot of
reach.
We're talking about 3 billion
users, millions of paying
businesses and paying customers.
And this is fundamental for why
you want to be on the Workspace
platform.
Finally I mentioned API's and
frameworks.
We've put a lot of effort in to
making sure that they are easy
to use and easy to build on.
When I say easy, easy from a
developer point of view.
It shouldn't take you months and
months to deduce how it works.
It should be something that you
could build up prototype in an
afternoon, and we believe that
we have made it that way for
you.
And finally, you've seen a lot
of logos on our slides today and
our discussion points today.
These are really proof points.
Atlassian, Miro, DocuSign, to
the success that our partners
are having, and the fact that we
believe in being better
together.
>> Absolutely.
Thanks, Matt.
Okay, Javier, we're coming back
to you.
>> Okay.
>> With a question from Laura.
>> Hello, Laura.
>> Laura is asking, with COVID
still keeping a lot of companies
remote, what is Google and
Google Workspace team doing to
offset the difficulties of
distributed work?
>> A lot, is the honest,
simplest answer.
Now, look, I think there's a --
it's a two-part answer.
From one side, as an
organi
organization, 2007 listen to
people.
We have to get feedback from
employees.
We've learned a lot from each
other, and about the different
situations that our employees
have to face on a daily basis.
It's informed our point of view,
as I mentioned earlier, this
idea of having an opinion.
We know that just because work
doesn't take place in a specific
named location anymore, that
there aren't, like, a whole host
of new problems and
opportunities that you have to
address, not just with products,
by the way, but also with
policies that accompany the
adopt, like recovery days and a
home office stipend, et cetera.
Now, from a product perspective,
we have this incredible
opportunity to channel those
learnings, along with the input
that we get from our customers
from around the world, and even
our users, to say, how are we
helping and how can we be more
helpful, I guess, in such a
broad, uniform sense of the
word, by helping people not just
use these products, but be
successful with them, and again,
this involves a whole lot of
listening, which is why I'm
great to have -- it's, you know
-- the dynamic experience here
with Cloud Next and also all
these great conversation with
users and customers that we've
been having everywhere.
So, you know, it's a
never-ending task.
>> Absolutely.
Across two parts.
The org and the product.
>> That's right.
That's right.
>> All right.
Well, it looks like we are out
of time.
So I'd like to thank everyone
for joining us today, and a huge
thank you to Javier, Erica and
Matt.
>> Thank you, Katie.
>> Of course!
It's great to be here all
together.
Thank you everyone online for
joining in today, and I'd like
to remind you that even though
we've finished the live Q&A, the
day is not over yet, and there's
actually another great session
that's about to begin shortly,
and it's from our own chief
diversity officer, Melonie
parker who's going to be leading
a DEI spotlight session that
talks about the importance of
STEM and creating pathways to
jobs in tech.
It's a really important topic
and I hope you all tune in to
check it out.
The details are on the next Web
site.
Thanks so much for joining us.
Bye.
>> Thanks, everybody.
>> Hello, everyone.
My name is Melonie Parker, and I
am Google's chief diversity
officer.
I would also like to introduce
Melanie, who's with us today.
She's going to be providing ASL
interpretation.
It is great to be back for my
third Google Cloud Next.
This time, for a look at
nurturing and developing
pathways to careers in tech.
Today, I'd like to talk about
how building a more diverse,
inclusive culture is not just a
competitive advantage for us at
Google, but it's a
responsibility as well.
And as we get started, I want to
let you know that the chat is
open so you can engage with each
other during this session.
I want you to share thoughts,
share where you're tuning in
from, and we'll have a few of
our folks on hand to join the
conversation.
We'll also get in to what we're
doing to widen pathways to tech
careers at Google and across our
industry.
But first, I am so proud to say
that Google is committed to
making diversity, equity and
inclusion a part of everything
we do.
From how we build our products
to how we build our workforce.
I work hand-in-hand with our
CEO, Sundar Pichai, and as part
of our executive leadership team
to bring our global DEI strategy
to life.
I also lead a passionate group
of people whose work touches
every 140,000 employees,
stretches across nearly 60
countries, and helps millions of
users who use our products and
our platforms to run their
households, their businesses and
their lives.
And personally, I travel down a
very unlikely path to land this
position.
I'm a black woman who grew up in
a small town in North Carolina.
My brother and I are proud
alumni of HBCUs, and we were the
first generation in our family
to bring home a college degree,
which I earned at a historically
black university, Hampton
University.
And unlike many of my peers, I
didn't have anyone at home to
explain the unwritten rules of
corporate America, or to help me
navigate my career.
Instead, I cobbled together a
community of mentors, managers
and inspirational voices who
helped me find my path.
And that's an idea that I want
to focus on today.
Access, opportunity and
networking are critically
important building blocks for a
successful tech career.
And that's especially true for
folks like me who come from
non-traditional backgrounds.
Too many people from
under-represented communities
find themselves confronting
systemic inequalities, such as a
lack of access to STEM education
or access to high-speed internet
that disrupt the pathway to tech
careers.
And for many who do navigate the
pathway, we've seen how the
weight of inequality can foster
a sense of imposter syndrome
once on the inside.
It's that sinking feeling of
doubt in our abilities, and a
feeling like a fraud, or that we
don't belong, and that for some,
it will linger for an entire
career.
Overcoming inequality and
creating access to opportunity,
including for our
under-represented talent, this
is a top priority at Google.
And we're taking decisive
actions that create
opportunities and steadily grow
a workforce that reflects the
world around us, to launch
programs that support our
communities globally, and to
build products that better serve
all of our users.
In other words, to build for
everyone, we need to weave
diverse perspectives into every
step of our design, engineering
and testing processes, and
innovative ideas can come from
everyone, from Googlers at the
grassroots level to engaged
leaders and to established
diversity councils across the
company.
As an example, the Google Meet
team worked on the light
enhancement feature to better
represent all skin tones in an
inclusive way during our video
calls, and through feedback from
a diverse group of testers, the
team was able to determine the
right algorithm that better
worked for all individuals
across the skin tone spectrum.
And this ensured that all video
calls on Meet work well for
everyone, and it was thanks to
the collaborative work and
questioning, how to make
products equitable for all.
In another example, Google has
internal teams to foster equity
through technology, empowering
our black + community to
innovate in the digital space by
supporting their educational
journey and helping them land
roles in the tech industry.
And we've also built external
programs like Cloud Career Jump
Start.
It's a 12-week learning course
for under-represented students
with computer science or
information systems-related
majors, or the relevant
experience, and it offers free
access to Google Cloud,
Associate Cloud engineer
training to prepare for the
certification exam.
We just published our diversity
annual report, and I am excited
to share that 2020 was our best
year yet for hiring our Black +
and Latinx + Googlers in the
U.S.
It was also our best year ever
for hiring women in tech in the
U.S. and globally.
In addition to hiring, we're
also re-doubling the focus on
retaining Googlers from all
under-represented groups, and in
full transparency, this is an
area where we can and we must do
better.
Google depends on the best,
brightest and most diverse
talent to not only help us solve
today's challenges, but also to
co-create solutions to
tomorrow's problems.
So we are building a lasting
model of inclusion and belonging
that helps all employees feel
seen, connected, supported, and
I hope proud to be in service.
Belonging is key to
re-recruiting our workforce and
acknowledging that not everyone
experiences our culture the same
way.
Despite our best efforts, some
team members are still feeling
left out.
There is work to do around
building the culture that we've
all been working so hard to
co-create.
Clearly, there's some other
missing element.
And as different as we are, we
all have the same underlying
need to feel valued, to feel
like our contributions matter,
to feel like we belong here.
But being included isn't
necessarily feeling like you
belong.
Being invited to the table is
not the same as being welcome at
the table, and being valued like
you belong.
Personally, I've been inspired
by the work of John Powell.
John is an expert in the areas
of civil rights and civil
liberties, and he's a professor
at Berkeley, and he leads the
Institute of Othering and
Belonging, and he looks at our
primal need as humans to belong.
And what fosters belonging and
what prevents it.
And if you think about it, one
of our primal fears is to be
ostracized by a group.
Aside from food and shelter, we
need to belong.
And we've evolved to ensure that
we could maintain access to the
resources that the group has.
Many behaviors are dictated by
this need to be accepted by
others.
But we're also guided by the
fear of losing that very
acceptance.
And we've evolved to protect
ourselves and our loved ones by
determining who's in and who's
out, and that comes down to
identifying who's the least
risk?
Those that we perceived most
like us and relegating those who
aren't to the out crowd.
And John calls that primal
sorting of people in to ins and
outs.
The cool kids versus the
non-cool kids, as othering, and
we don't necessarily do this
consciously, but it is the
behavior that stems from our
unconscious bias.
The subtle ways that we send
messages, even virtually, of
who's cool and who's not, who's
valued, who's not.
And that's why I believe that
our work, it's not truly
possible until we foster this
sense of belonging.
And as evolved humans, we have
control over this.
There are ways to check in with
ourselves, noticing, are we
turning inward, focusing on only
who and what we know, versus
turning outward to connect with
and explicitly work with other
groups, and to seek ways to
build common ground.
And that would foster belonging
and empathy.
And this means that we need to
co-create the workplace
experience with our internal
communities, and redefine what
it means to be a Googler by
acknowledging where we can do
better.
And by enduring everyone feels
like they belong, is positioned
to do their best work, and can
confidently bring their
authentic whole selves to work
each day.
And for under-represented
talent, this can make the
difference between surviving and
thriving in their career.
And for those of you who are
accustomed to muting parts of
who we are, authenticity
empowers us to do our very best
work.
Last summer, at the start of the
global racial justice movement,
I realized that I could no
longer code switch or check
parts of myself at the door in
an act of self preservation.
Definite
To lead our deep work in racial
equity and address the systemic
and structural barriers, I
needed to reconcile the most
vulnerable parts of my own
identity as a Black woman, with
the Black woman who happens to
lead diversity at Google.
And I know that this is the type
of workplace environment that we
strive to build.
And with our collective,
consistent efforts, that is what
we'll do.
We know that Google is most
helpful when our products and
our services reflect the needs
of the people who are using
them.
To best serve our diverse global
community of users, we need a
more representative workforce,
and while we're making progress,
we know equalities persist
around access, opportunity and
networking for under-represented
talent, but through investments
in creating pathways to STEM,
and with help from allies, we
can broaden the talent pipeline,
improve product design, and
fulfill our mission of making
DEI part of everything that we
do.
What does this look like?
There's a real cognitive shift
happening both inside and
outside of Google around
diversity, equity and inclusion
and how we can best build for
everyone.
Externally, we're creating
pathways to careers in tech as
early as elementary and high
school.
We're expanding recruitment
beyond the usual campuses like
Stanford, Berkeley, Harvard,
Yale, and doubling down on
higher education institutions
like Hispanic-serving
institutions, and historically
black colleges and universities
serving under-represented
talent.
Why?
Because we know that 25 percent
of Black graduates with STEM
degrees, for example, they come
from HBCUs, just like the one I
attended.
So this year, we began deepening
and sustaining relationships
with HBCUs.
In June, we announced an
historic, unrestricted $50
million grant that allows the
presidents of these esteemed
institutions to allocate
resources in the manner that
they see fit.
We're also broadening career
pathways to include a major grow
with Google career readiness
investment that supports our
Hispanic-serving institutions
around the U.S.
A significant economic
opportunity grant for workforce
development and digital skills
training to thousands of
Hispanics, and a career
readiness program for Native
American, indigenous serving
institutions.
And that's just a slice of the
work that we're doing
externally.
And while I mentioned that 2020
was Google's biggest year in
terms of hiring Black and Latinx
talent in the U.S., we know that
there's much more work to do
inside of Google to retain and
grow our talent.
So broadly speaking, we've
developed racial equity
education for all Googlers, and
incorporated it into our new
hire orientation.
We've doubled the size of our
retention and progression team
and we're on the path to triple
this team by 2022, and this
enables us to provide one-to-one
support like coaching,
networking and internal mobility
opportunities to help
under-represented Googlers grow
and thrive.
And we rolled out an innovative
onboarding program for our new
Black Googlers so that they feel
more supported right from the
start.
Our employees want to know that
they can grow and thrive with
us, and that's one reason why
we're working to increase
leadership representation among
women, Black and Latinx
Googlers.
We've introduced pathways to
sponsorship for women in
technical leadership roles.
It's designed to accelerate
their careers.
We leverage partnerships with
more than two dozen community
and professional organizations,
and these partners offer
professional development, as
well as networking opportunities
for under-represented Googlers.
We also offer skills building
initiatives like the Cloud
Technical Residency Program, and
with great intention, we've
begun building a culture of
belonging for all Googlers, as I
described earlier.
We've been very open about our
successes and our challenges,
and I invite you to explore this
further at diversity.google.com.
Now, I know many of you are
wondering what can I do?
So as you weigh your own
strategies around engagement and
retention, consider the role of
allies in driving results.
Allies can be leaders, managers
and peers.
They support folks in
marginalized groups to which
they don't identify.
Internally, we've created a
number of pathways for allies
that are seeking to support our
under-represented colleagues.
These include an allyship
pathway with group exercises for
allies and resources for
practicing or encouraging
inclusive behaviors.
We also have Google in
Residence.
Experience Google's software
engineers, teach introductory
computer science classes on HBCU
campuses, and we have faculty in
Residence.
We have more than 50 faculty
members from 30 HBCUs to design
project-based industry-informed
content and to implement that
content in their classrooms.
Google has doubled in size in
the past few years.
We know our DEI commitments need
to keep pace.
Operating at this global scale,
it heightens our sense of
responsibility around DEI, and
to paraphrase my colleague,
Annie Jean-Baptiste, there's no
blueprint to doing this
perfectly.
And while we don't have all the
answers, we're eager to share
what we've learned and also to
learn from others.
And in the spirit of learning
leadership, I hope I'll be
invited to share more
discoveries and progress at
Google Cloud Next 22.
In closing, when our mission is
to build for everyone, we have
to work with everyone.
So with help from allies and
through smart investments and
creating pathways to STEM
careers, I am confident our
talent pipeline will flourish.
Real, meaningful change can take
years.
We know.
But there's no need to wait for
change to come.
If you haven't already, please
head over to the chat room and
join the discussion.
There, you can share some of
your successes and your
challenges around creating
pathways to tech careers.
This kind of dialogue can open
minds and truly inspire change.
I look forward to sharing more
progress with you next year, and
I'll bring others along who have
been on this journey with us to
share their experiences.
Thank you for wrapping up Day 1
of Google Cloud Next with me.
It's been great sharing this
time with you.
We look forward to seeing you
all here tomorrow for Day 2,
which kicks off with our
developer keynote.
Until then, be sure to register
atg.co/cloudnext for access to
all of our content, and join the
conversation on social using
#Googlecloudnext.
See you tomorrow!